GO AHEAD AND START S A
SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT AT THIS
TIME. WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MEETING OF
JULY SEVENTH- WHAT THE FOR THE
SECRETARY HOLE OF A CALLING
ROLE UNTIL WE HAVE A FORM-
ONCE- CORMS BEEN ESTABLISHED
THROUGH MOLE WILL MOVE FORWARD
FULL COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME THE TWENTY MEMBERS WHO
ARE PRESENT- IN THE PUBLIC TO
TODAY'S HEARING. WE HAVE TWELVE
BILLS ON FILE TODAY ONE BILL
HAS BEEN PULLED THAT BILL IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB SIX
NINE NINE. THERE ARE FIVE
MEASURES ON CONSENT THEY ARE IN
FILE ORDER SB SEVEN OH FIVE SB
THREE NINE THREE SB FOUR
HUNDRED WITH AMENDMENTS SB
SEVEN TWO TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
SB NINETY SEVEN WITH US AGAIN
THOSE MEASURES ARE ON CONSENT.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE HEARING THE
BILLS AND FILE ORDER IF YOU ARE
STAFF MEMBER. YOU NEED TO GET
YOUR US SENATOR HERE. GO AHEAD
LOOK AT THE- THE FILE ORDER AND
GET THEM HERE- IN ORDER TO MOVE
THROUGH OUR CHEN EFFICIENTLY WE
WILL ATTEMPT TO SPEND. NO MORE
THAN TWENTY MINUTES ON EACH
BILL WITH NO MORE THAN TEN
MINUTES OF PUBLIC COMMENT. ON
THE PHONE. BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH
OUR AGENDA I HAVE A STATEMENT
TO READ REGARDING OUR PROCESS
TODAY. THE ASSEMBLY IS
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WORN BY
PEOPLE PRESENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM IF YOU DO NOT HAVE ASKED
WE WILL PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL YOU MAY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. WHEN WE INVITE
COMMENTS FROM PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM AS PEOPLE IN THE ROOM.
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
PHONE TELL OF TELEPHONE SERVICE
FOR TESTIMONY. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE JUST GO TO THAT AND
WILL BE ON THE SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO. AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOU ARE TESTIFYING IS
BEGINNING THEIR PRESENTATION SO
AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO TESTIFY ON
A BILL. OKAY DON'T DON'T DON'T
BRING ANY TESTIMONY ON ANYTHING
OTHER THE BILLS WERE HEARING
TODAY. OF YOU DO I DO WISH TO
TESTIFY WHEN THE AUTHOR STARTS
PRESENTING THE BILL YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY ON. THAT'S WHEN YOU
WANT TO CALL AND DON'T CALL IN
BEFORE. DON'T CALL IN AFTER THE
MODERATOR- SHOULD CUT ANYONE
OFF WHO DOES NOT- SIMPLY STATE
THEIR NAME- AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. ANYTHING
ELSE. AND WE'RE AND WE'RE NOT
HERE TO HEAR TODAY- THOSE ARE
THE RULES SO THAT EVERYBODY CAN
BE HER AND EVERYBODY CAN BE
WITH YOU EVERY CAN BE Y. AND-
EVERYTHING WHEN. PLEASE FATHER
MODERATORS INSTRUCTIONS SO YOU
TESTIFY ON THE CORRECT BILL.
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE AS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES WE WILL NOT HEAR
YOU. IF YOU DO NOT DO THAT. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THIS MODERATE A TELEPHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT
SEVEN. AGAIN MODERATOR PLEASE
OF ANYONE- WISHES TO GO OFF- IN
AND NOT FOLLOW THE DIRECTION
PLEASE IMMEDIATELY CUT THEM OFF
SO WE CAN PROCEED TO THE NEXT
CALLER.SO THAT EVERYBODY WHO
WANTS TO BE HEARD. WILL BE
HEARD. THERE IS ALSO A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION IN CAPITOL
PARK ON THE NORTH STEPS OF THE
CAPITOL JUST OUTSIDE. THE
COMMITTEE ALSO- ACCEPTS WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE PORT
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE YOU CAN
SUBMIT THEIR- FINALLY I WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS DISRUPTIONS TO
OUR HEARING PROCESS THE
ASSEMBLY HAS RECENTLY
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO OUR COMMITTEES.
AND FLOOR PROCEEDINGS. CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS THE STRIPS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE- ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED AND SUCH CONDUCT MAY
INCLUDE REMOVING A MASK. IT
TALKING LOUDLY MAKING LOUD
NOISES- UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE
SPEAKING LONGER. THAN THAN THE
ALLOTTED TIME. EXTENDED
DISCUSSION OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT. OF THE
HEARING OR BILL. AND IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WHEN FOLKS CALL AND
WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
BILL WHEN YOU WHAT YOU DO IS
WHEN YOU CALL YOU STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY. TO ADDRESS
ANY DISRUPTIONS IT WILL TAKE
THE FOLLOWING STEPS ON THE
PHONES WILL JUST CUT YOU OFF
MOVE THE NEXT CALLER- IF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPT HER HEARING
I WILL DIRECT THEM TO STOP. AND
THEN WARRANT AND THEN MORE THAN
THAT CONTINUE DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN THEIR REMOVAL FROM
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. WE ALSO
DOCUMENT THAT YEAH IF THE
CONDUCT DOES NOT STOP IT WITH-
WE'LL REQUEST IS THE ASSISTANCE
OF THE SERGEANTS AND ESCORTING
YOU OUT OF THE BUILDING. WITH
THAT WERE GOING TO. OKAY WITH
THAT ALTHOUGH WE DO HAVE QUORUM.
WE. GO AHEAD AND COOK SECRETARY
PLEASE COLORADO- DENTAL CARE
HERE. KILEY BENNETT BENNETT
HERE DALLY LEAD THEIR LEAGUE
HERE MCCARTY QUICK SILVA.
QUIKSILVER HERE OF COURSE WE DO
HAVE A FORM ESTABLISH. YOU ARE
FOR FILLED. WITH WE DO HAVE A
CO OWNER AND- HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED DO WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR PRESENT. SENATE IS VERY
SLOW TODAY THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARE ALL HERE. NOT ALL THE MOST
OF THEM. I WAS TOLD SOME THE
CENTERS AREN'T EVEN IN THE
BUILDING SO THAT'S PRETTY BAD
WE'RE NOT GOING TO WAIT ALL DAY
FOR THEM THEY NEED TO GET HER
HEARING STARTED AND IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO START AT NINE.
THAT.
I DID IT AGAIN FOR THE HELP.
OKAY.
OKAY. AFTER YEAH COUPLE
OF. OKAY. HOPE. TO YES. YEAH
SENATOR CORTESE IS PRESENT IN
THE ROOM- HE'S GOT- FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE THAT'S SB SIX NINE
TWO IS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE.
SENATOR CORTESE WILL NOT
PERCENT AND JUST SO FOLKS KNOW
THAT WE HAVE- FOR EACH BILL
THERE'S TO BE ALLOWED TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
MINUTES EACH TODAY WE- WE DID A
GRANT- MISTER CORTESE'S ASK
WHICH WAS TO HAVE SOMEONE. WHO
I BELIEVE IS NEUTRAL NOW- ON
THE BILL- TESTIFIED AS WELL SO
THAT SENATOR YOU MAY PROCEED
ONE READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SOME. A
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB SIX
NINETY TO THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
INCLUSION ACT. THE BILL
CENTERED AROUND THE PRINCIPLE
OF EQUITY IN OUR SCHOOL
CLASSROOMS AND- FORMED A
PARTNERSHIP IN NUMEROUS PARENTS
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
DISABILITY RIGHTS GROUPS.
SPECIAL EDUCATION EXPERTS
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS.
INCLUSION FOR PROVIDING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES OR ENGAGE WITH
THEIR PEERS IN GENERAL
EDUCATION CLASSROOMS HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATE TO INCREASE
ACADEMIC GRADUATION OUTCOMES
FOR NOT ONLY SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS. BUT ALL STUDENTS.
STATES THAT HAVE INCREASED
INCLUSION L. R. E. RATES OVER
THE LAST DECADE INCLUDING
MASSACHUSETTS NEW JERSEY AND
FLORIDA HAVE SEEN PARALLEL
INCREASES IN THE ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. CALIFORNIA'S RATE
OF INCLUSION IS LOW IN
COMPARISON TO OTHER STATES. IN
ALMOST BUT NO PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE TOWARD GREATER INCLUSION
FOR STUDENTS IN THE LAST
DECADE. ONLY 53% OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
SPENT A MAJORITY OF THEIR
SCHOOL THEN A GENERAL EDUCATION
CLASSROOM. THAT'S WELL BELOW
OUR NATIONAL AVERAGE OF 63%
ABOUT A 10% DIFFERENCE. BY
ADDING AN EXISTING FEDERAL
INCLUSION OR LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT TARGET HOPE WHICH
IS THE ACRONYM IS EARLIER. TO
EXISTING STATE ACCOUNTABILITY A
TO THE DASHBOARD FOR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND
AWARENESS OF INCLUSION OPTIONS
FOR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
HELP TO ALIGN TO FRAGMENTED
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEMS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY APPLY TO STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES. AND
DISINCENTIVE EYES DISTRICT FROM
INAPPROPRIATELY PLACING THOSE
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS INTO
SEGREGATED CLASSROOMS THAT
BEING SAID. IT SHOULD BE
CLARIFIED THAT WE UNDERSTAND.
THAT THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT FOR EVERY STUDENT
MAY NOT BE THE GENERAL
EDUCATION SETTINGS. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION PROGRAM I
E. P. THAT TEAM AND THE FAMILY
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THE RIGHT
TO DETERMINE. THE MOST
APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT. OF A
STUDENT WITH DISABILITIES. THIS
BILL WILL ENCOURAGE DISTRICTS
TO OFFER MORE INCLUSIVE OPTIONS
TO STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
INCENTIVIZE DISTRICTS TO USE
EXISTING RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
GENERAL EDUCATION TEACHERS WITH
TRAINING. AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ON TEACHING
STRATEGIES AND FRAMEWORKS
OPTIMIZE EDUCATION FOR
STUDENTS. WITH INDIVIDUAL
LEARNING DIFFERENCES. SB SIX
NINETY TWO. WILL THEREBY BE
ABLE TO IMPROVE THE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE THROUGH
INCLUSION TO STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES LAYING THE
FOUNDATION FOR FUTURE
LEGISLATION FOCUS ON
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES OF
INCLUSION UNDERSTANDING AND
EQUITY. BEFORE INTRODUCED BY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL I WANT TO MAKE NOTE THAT
AMENDMENTS WERE MADE- IN THE
SENATE IN PARTNERSHIP MANY
ADVOCATES ORGANIZATIONS AND
LEADERS FOR TAKING THE DEAF.
AND HARD OF HEARING COMMUNITY
THE BLIND COMMUNITY AND THE
DEAF BLIND COMMUNITY. SUMMER
HERE TODAY WILL ALSO BE
TESTIFYING. THEY WILL BE
PROVIDED TESTIMONY AS I
UNDERSTAND IT WITH THE NEUTRAL
STANCE THESE PRIOR AMENDMENTS
WERE MADE A PARTNERSHIP WITH
THEM AND SERVED ME
CLARIFICATIONS TO ADDRESS OUR
INITIAL CONCERNS REGARDING THIS
BILL. I WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT THIS BILL WOULD NOT ALTER
pOF HEARING BLIND OR DEAF BLIND
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. NOR
WOULD HAVE ANY IMPACT ON STATE
SPECIAL SCHOOLS OUR SPECIALTY
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE LOW
INCIDENT STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. AND THOSE PRIOR
AMENDMENTS MADE TO THE BILL
CLARIFY THIS. ALSO ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED BY THIS COMMITTEE
THAT ARE LISTED IN THE STAFF
ANALYSIS. THESE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY HOW THE NEW INDICATOR
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
DASHBOARD. TO ENSURE A FULL
PICTURE IS BEING PAINTED ON THE
STUDENTS BEING SERVED WITH
ADEQUATE CONTEXT GIVEN AND I
WANT TO JUST EXTEND- A LITTLE
OFF SCRIPT MY HEART FULL. OF
GRATITUDE TO THE CHAIR FOR
SPENDING SO MUCH TIME WITH ME
PERSONALLY- AS WELL AS-
COMMITTEE STAFF. WORKING WITH
ME AND MY STAFF THE TO TRY TO
GET THE LANGUAGE EXACTLY RIGHT
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO GET IT
RIGHT AND I AND I THINK WE'VE
DONE THAT HERE. WITH ME TODAY
IS DR MERION TO WANT THE SENECA
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
KEVIN SCHAEFER DIRECTOR OF THE
SUPPORTING INCLUSION PRACTICES
PROJECT. OF IT WHICH IS PART OF
THE- ARTICLE ELDORADO COUNTY
OFFICE EDUCATION. ALSO TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR WHEN I GO TO
THE PHONES FOR EACH WITNESSES
THERE ARE TWO WITNESSES OF WITH
TWO MINUTES EACH. YOU MAY
PROCEED DR MARIANNE- THE. ONE
GOOD MORNING I'M BACK TO MARION
TO ONE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS.
CRAFTED BURNT THERE SENATE BILL
SIX NINETY TWO AND WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR DEEP APPRECIATION
TO SENATOR CORTES DE FOR
BRINGING FORWARD THAT SPARTAN
THOUGH THAT PRIORITIZES EQUITY
AND INCLUSION WHICH ARE CORD
COLORS OF OUR OFFICE. I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR LONG
STANDING COMMITMENT TO
INCLUSION. I STARTED MY CAREER
AS A SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER
AND HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND THAT
INCLUSION CHANGES THAT YOUR
DIRECTORY A STUDENT BY.
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES WHO
ARE INCLUDED AND GENERAL
EDUCATION CLASSES ARE MORE
LIKELY TO KEEP PACE WITH PEERS
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL CAREER. OVER THIRTY
YEARS OF EVIDENCE BASED
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES EXTERIOR
BECAUSE THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN INCLUSION AND ACADEMIC
GRADUATION AND EMPLOYMENT
SUCCESS. YET CALIFORNIA HAS
FAILED TO MAKE ANY SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS TOWARD GREATER
INCLUSION. CALIFORNIA ONLY
REGULARLY INCLUDES ABOUT 53% OF
OUR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
AND GENERAL EDUCATION CLASSES
FAR BELOW THE NATIONAL RATE.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY TWO
WOULD NOT REQUIRE THAT A 100%
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
BE INCLUDED A 100% OF THE TIME.
IT WOULD ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS
OFFER MORE INCLUSIVE
OPPORTUNITIES AND OPTIONS TO
STUDENTS WITH EIGHTY. WE
BELIEVE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE IMPORTANT AND
ESSENTIAL MEMBERS OF THE
GENERAL EDUCATION COMMUNITY AND
ARE DESERVING OF EQUAL DIGNITY
AND INCLUSION WITH THEIR PEERS.
WE URGE YOU TO JOIN US BY
VOTING YES ON SENATE BILL SIX
NINETY TWO. THANK YOU THANK YOU
TO OUR NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KEVIN
SCHAEFER DIRECTOR OF EQUITY AND
INCLUSIVE PRACTICES FOR THE
SUPPORTING INCLUSIVE PRACTICES
PROJECT WHICH IS FUNDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. I ALONG WITH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR KRISTEN
BROOKS ADMINISTER THE PROJECT
THROUGH THE EL DORADO AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION RESPECTIVELY. OUR
MISSION TO SUPPORT LEADERSHIP
IN THEIR INTENTIONAL DESIGN AND
REDESIGN INCREASE MEANINGFUL
INCLUSIVE OPPORTUNITIES
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES WITH
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION INDICATOR FIVE EGG
WHICH IS AT THE CENTER OF THE
BILL. ALMOST FIFTY YEARS AGO I
WAS A STUDENT THAT THAT. WHO
EXPERIENCE EXCLUSIONARY
PRACTICES AS WELL AT THE AFTER
ABOUT. FIFTY YEARS AGO AND
STILL FAR TOO OFTEN WE CONTINUE
TO EDUCATE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IT SEGREGATED
SETTINGS CANCEL END. EVEN TODAY
ROUGHLY HALF OF THE STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE EDUCATED IN SEPARATE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT. DEFECTOR
IN MOST CASES NEGATIVELY CAN
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION AND
LIMITED CAREER OPPORTUNITIES.
WE MUST DO BETTER AT DOING
BETTER INCLUDE ADDING INDICATOR
FIVE EIGHT LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT DATA AT THE
REQUIRED AND TRANSPARENT
MEASURE ON THE CALIFORNIA
ACCOUNTABILITY DASHBOARD. BUT
STILL ALLOWS FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
I PLEASE MAKE THE DECISIONS
MADE BY IDT TEAMS COULD BE
FRONT AND CENTER AS OPPOSED TO
AN ABLEIST AFTERTHOUGHT WICKS I
LOOKED DISTRICT PLANNING
CONVERSATION. I KNOW FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE THAT THE
INCLUSION. EXCEPT MY CAREER TO
CREATING AN INCLUSIVE LEARNING
SPACE OF ALL STUDENTS THE DARK.
REMEMBER THAT SEPARATE IS NOT
EQUAL- I URGE YOU TO VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. SIX NINETY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK MMHM I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE A WITNESSES IN
OFFICE TO THIS WE DO HAVE ONE
THAT WANTS TO EXPLAIN THEIR
NEUTRAL POSITION TODAY. AND
THAT IS- SHERRY FOR HEARING
FOLLOW HEARING HER INA I
BELIEVE I SAID THAT CORRECTLY-
SO YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THROUGH AN INTERPRETER. THE
TECHNICIANS. SAN RACE DAY THERE
FROM QUESTIONS. THE. TWO I.
DON'T THINK. WE CANNOT. OKAY.
GOOD MORNING. I'M REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION AND
AGENCIES SERVING THE DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING AS WELL AS THE-
ORGANIZATION OR TEACHERS OF THE
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING CALLED
CAL ED. WE CHANGED OUR POSITION
FROM A OPPOSITION TO NEUTRAL
ONCE THAT THIS BILL WAS AMENDED
TO ADD THE EXCEPTION FOR DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR LEGISLATORS
TO UNDERSTAND A FEW MAIN
REASONS. THIS BILL SITES. A
SINGLE FEDERAL INDICATOR FIVE A
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU ALL UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
NOT A COMPLIANCE INDICATOR IT
IS NOT A REQUIREMENT THERE ARE
ALSO NINETEEN OTHER INDICATORS.
MY SECOND MAIN REASON IS TOO
MANY DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
STUDENTS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
MAINSTREAM WITHOUT ADEQUATE
SUPPORT WITHOUT EDUCATORS AND
PEERS. AND REGULAR EDUCATION
AND BEING ABLE TO COMPLETELY
COMMUNICATE AND THEIR PRIMARY
LANGUAGE. WHETHER IT IS ENGLISH
OR AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE.
EDUCATIONAL PLACEMENTS NEEDS TO
BE BASED ON WHAT IS BEST FOR
THAT STUDENT NOT WHAT IS BEST
FOR THE SYSTEM OR FOR MEETING
IN L. R. E. QUOTA. WE HAVE AN
EPIDEMIC OF LANGUAGE
DEPRIVATION AMONG DEAF AND HARD
OF HEARING CHILDREN. AND
STUDENTS WERE NOT MEETING THEIR
ACADEMIA DUE TO LANGUAGE
BARRIERS. WHICH IS KEY THE
WORLD FEDERATION FOR THE DEAF
PRESIDENT RECENT STATEMENT
RELATED TO THE EDUCATION OF
DEAF STUDENTS. QUOTES INCLUSION
IS AN EXPERIENCE IT IS A
HOLISTIC EXPERIENCE IT IS NOT A
PLACEMENT END QUOTE. EVERY
STUDENT IN THE CLASSROOM WHO
CAN EXPERIENCE FULLY FREE
FLOWING COMMUNICATION WITH EACH
OTHER AND WITH THEIR TEACHERS
THAT'S INCLUSION. MANY MANY
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
STUDENTS ARE ISOLATED IN
REGULAR CLASSROOMS ONLY
RECEIVING ONE HOUR A WEEK OF
ITINERANT SERVICES THAT IS NOT
INCLUSION. LASTLY WE NEED A
BILL THAT WILL DIRECTLY ADDRESS
THE EDUCATION OF DEAF AND HARD
OF HEARING CHILDREN IN THIS
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- THE
TERMINAL DONNA. GERMAN ARE DONE
YES- IF WILL WILL GO TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NOW. IF SO
MISTER BENNETT I COULD JUST
MAKE OF A PERSONAL COMMENT. OF
MY BROTHER'S DEATH. AND HE WAS
MAINSTREAMED AND HE SUFFERED
GREATLY SO I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND I APPRECIATE THE
DEAF ORGANIZATION OF STANDING
UP FOR THE UNIQUE REASONS WHY
THERE NEED TO BE THIS EXCLUSION
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT AND I
TOO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH ME IN MY
OFFICE I DIDN'T KNOW YOU WHEN
YOU WALKED IN MY OFFICE- BUT I
CAME TO UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM YOU HAVE A GREAT
PASSION FOR THIS ISSUE. BUT YOU
CARE HE REALLY DO CARE ABOUT
THIS WE SEE A LOT OF BILLS WERE
MAYBE PEOPLE AREN'T INVESTED
BUT YOU'RE REALLY INVESTED IN
THIS BILL HE DID A GREAT JOB
AND I KNOW WE HAD SOME
CONCERNS- REALLY MY MAIN
CONCERN COMES AS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER. ALONG THE LINES OF
PROBABLY WHAT I'D LABELED
RECIPROCAL ACCOUNTABILITY RIGHT
BECAUSE JUST JUST JUST PUTTING
STUDENTS SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS
INTO A CLASSROOM. THAT IS AN
INCLUSION RIGHT- THEY NEED TO
BE SUPPORTED THE STUDENT NEEDS
TO BE SUPPORTED AND THE TEACHER
NEEDS TO BE SUPPORTED OR AS AS
BEEN ALLUDED TO THAT STUDENTS
GOING TO BE ALONE IN THAT
CLASSROOM THAT WAS VIEWED ONE
WAY THAT IT CONTINUES TO BE ONE
OF MY BIG CONCERNS AND YOURS
TOO WE WERE GREETED WORK ON
THAT GOING FORWARD. HOW DO WE
BUILD THAT INTO POLICY- I'LL
GIVE AN EXAMPLE I STILL GO BACK
IN THE CLASSROOM AND SUB- AS A
TEACHER AND I WAS IN A
CLASSROOM MODE I DID SOME LAST
YEAR THE YEAR PRIOR WHERE ONE
OF THE PERIOD SAID THAT WHAT
THEY CALL INCLUSION. BUT A
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS THERE WERE
SPECIAL NEEDS WELL THAT WAS
AROUND THE INCLUSION FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THERE IS NO
SUPPORT. FOR THE STUDENTS OR
THE TEACHER IN THAT CLASSROOM
SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET THIS RIGHT SO THAT WE BEST
SERVE THE NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS
AND I KNOW YOU AGREE WITH THAT
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO HAVE A AND I CNVERSATIONS.
ABOUT GOING FORWARD AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT WITH YOU THANK YOU FOR
THE BILL- WITHOUT ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. OF COURSE OR- WHEN
YOU GET TEACHER. ON THAT THE- A
COMMITTEE HERE WE ALL HAVE SOME
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES BUT- I TO
WHO HAVE TAUGHT IN KATIE- SIX
FOR. ALMOST THIRTY YEARS. HAVE
HAD MANY STUDENTS THAT WERE
MAINSTREAM DAN- MOSTLY- WHAT
AUTISTIC STUDENTS BUT THAT
MEANS THAT IT IS MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT THAN- I THINK THE
PUBLIC IS AWARE. FOR TEACHERS
TO DO THE BEST JOB CAN. UP WITH
THIRTY TWO TH THREE FOUR
STUDENTS. ARE AN THEN TO HAVE A
STUDENTS WITH NEEDS I HAVEN'T A
TEACHER THAT. DID LITTLE FOR
FEW THINGS OUT OF THE BOX LIKE
PLAYED A LOT OF MUSIC AND
POETRY AND HAVE THE MOVE AROUND
AND SOME OF THE PARENTS TOLD ME
THEY THRIVE BUT THERE'S OTHER
TIMES WHERE PARTICULARLY WITH
TECHNOLOGY THEY'RE SITTING IN A
CLASS AND MANY TIMES POWER
POINTS AND ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT TYPES- AND IT'S VERY
QUIET PLACE AND THEY CAN. VERY
EASILY. HEY AND I'D BE THE
FIRST TO SAY THAT- TEACHERS DO
A GREAT JOB BUT IT IS HARD TO
MEET ALL OF THOSE NEEDS IN ONE
CLASSROOM BUT THE BIGGEST THING
I SAW IS THE SUPPORT STAFF AS
MUCH AS THEY WOULD TRY.
SOMETIMES YOU WOULD GET THIRTY
MINUTES. THAT FOR THAT ONE
STUDENT WHO DIDN'T HIRE DAY AND
SOMETIMES THEY'D WALK IN AND
YOU WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF
SOMETHING SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
REALLY FOCUSING ON THIS
BECAUSE- WE WANT TO DO THE BEST
FOR KIDS AND WE WANT TO DO. ALL
WE CAN BUT WITH ONE TEACHER
TYPICALLY AND A VERY SMALL
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT TIME
SOMETIMES WE DON'T ALWAYS DO IT
THE RIGHT WAY SO I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. GREAT SEEING NO
FURTHER COMMENT FROM ANY OF THE
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE
NOW GOING TO GO TO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT- TEN MINUTES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION FROM IN THE ROOM
ON THE PHONE AND AT THE STATION
IN CAPITOL PARK. SO IF YOU ARE
ON THE PHONE OR IN THE ROOM OR
IN CAPITOL PARK WHAT YOU DO NOW
YOU CAN STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY NOTHING MORE THAN
THAT. AND IT SHOULD BE ON THIS
BILL ODERATOR PLEASE CUT
ANYONE OFF WHO- WHO DOES NOT
ADHERE TO THAT PLEASE- SO IN
THE ROOM OTHER ANYWAY ANY ANY
PERSONS IN THEIR OWN WISH TO.
SHARE THEIR OPINION SINGLE
PERSONS IN THE ROOM WE'LL GO TO
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION IN
CAPITOL PARK. I BELIEVE THERE
IS NO ONE AND THEN CAPITOL
PARK. NOW WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONES- MODERATOR TO THE PHONES
PLEASE. SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
YOU IF YOU'RE MUCH ONCE AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO WILL FIRST GO TO
LINE OF FIFTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING WITH
TCRC ON BEHALF OF PERVERSE I
CAN ONLY SEE PER INTENDED TO
FOLD AND SUPPORT. TOTAL ITEMS
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND WITH THE
ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT WE CAN MOVE OUR
POSITION TO SUPPORT AND I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THE SENATOR. BLACK THANK
YOU AT THE TIME AS LINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING I MEAN THE TENANT CHECK
REPRESENTING DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND BEER IN SUPPORT
OF THE FILM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND FOR THAT TIME. GREAT I
THANK YOU ARE WITH THAT THE
AUTHOR MAY CLOSE. AGAIN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- TO
COMMITTEE STAFF INTO THE
MEMBERS- WITH ALL OF YOU IN
PARTICULAR CHAIR FOR A SHARING
YOUR INSIGHT MY EXPERIENCE I'VE%
FOUND OUT AS A BOSS YOUR SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER AND EVEN MY
EXPERIENCES INTO MY WIFE IS AN
EDUCATOR- PALES IN COMPARISON
TO THE ACTUAL LIVES
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE OF
STAYING IN FRONT OF. A
CLASSROOM OF STUDENTS IN IN
TEACHING AND- YOUR HELP HAS
BEEN INVALUABLE TO GET US TO
THIS POINT THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR APPLE
THANK YOU SENATOR GOOD JOB- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO WE HAVE A
MOTION. IT'S BEEN. IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED. THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL BY DONAL I HIGHLY
HIGHLY I'D BENNETT BENNETT I
DALLY. DALLY I LEE. MCCARTY
CORK SILVA PHOTO BY FIVE OF
THOSE FIVE- TODAY'S OUT THANK
YOU SENATOR OKAY THANK YOU
AGAIN I THINK CENTER LATER THIS
YEAR. ALEXANDER LAMONT'S. RIGHT
BOETTCHER RIGHT THERE. OKAY
OKAY THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS OF
WE ARE ON DISNEY AND JOB WE ARE
ON A. FILE ITEM SO FILE I SO- A.
FIFTY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL AS A WORKING MOTHER WITH
AN INFANT I HAVE STRUGGLED WITH
HEALTH CARE OPTIONS MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS FACE THE SAME
STRUGGLES CURRENTLY UR SYSTEM
IS ONLY SERVING 10% OF ELIGIBLE
INFANTS AND TODDLERS THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR CHILD CARE
AND SB FIFTY WILL ADDRESS
INEFFICIENCIES IN THE SYSTEM TO
BETTER SERVE CHILDREN FAMILIES
AND PROVIDERS. THIS BILL DOES
NOT REQUIRE PROVIDERS TO MAKE
ANY CHANGES BUT DOES ALLOW
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND
PARENTS MORE FLEXIBILITY THIS
BILL WILL OPEN UP THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO YOUNGER
CHILDREN BY OPENING UP THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO
CHILDREN EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
FIVE YEARS WE CAN SERVE MORE
UNDERSERVED TODDLERS
ADDITIONALLY SB FIFTY WILL MAKE
IT EASIER FOR FAMILIES TO
ENROLL AND STEAMROLLED IN CHILD
CARE IT EASES THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON
PARENTS AND PROVIDERS BY
ESTABLISHING TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
OF CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY AND
ALLOWING FOR SOME STREAMLINED
ELIGIBILITY. IF A PRENT CAN
SIT THERE AND ROLLED IN
PROGRAMS LIKE MEDICARE HEALTH
HEALTH FIRST WEEK AND HEAD
START THEY WILL BE PRESUMED
ELIGIBLE FOR SUBSIDIZED HEALTH
CARE TODAY- WE HAVE ANDREA
FERNANDES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S ACADEMY AND NINA OF
BEAUTY FROM A EVERY TELL
CALIFORNIA TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. TO OUR
FIRST WITNESS. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANDREA FERNANDEZ THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S ACADEMY A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WE'RE CENTER BATES I DON'T BUY
A DIRECT CONTRACTOR WE SERVE
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED INCIDENTS
FATHERS SOME PRESCHOOLERS ARE
FULL DAY FULL YEAR PROGRAM AND
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY.
THE CHANGES THAT THE FIFTY
PROPOSES TO MAKE IT TO THE
CURRENT CALIFORNIA STATE
CRITICAL SYSTEM WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY HELP FAMILIES
ACCESS SERVICES IN FAMILIES OF
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED FOR OTHER
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS SUCH AS
MEDICARE CALFRESH THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR SERVICES BY
PROVIDING PROOF OF THAT AWARD.
CURRENTLY OUR FAMILIES IN THE
PROVIDE THEIR ELIGIBILITY FOR
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE OVER AND
OVER AGAIN WITH EACH PROGRAM
HAVING TO CERTIFY THE FAMILY
SEPARATELY THIS CREATES A
BARRIER FOR THE FAMILIES WHO
MAY HAVE TO GATHER NEW
DOCUMENTATION EACH AND EVERY
TIME AND THEN WAIT WHILE EACH
PROGRAM WORKS TO CONFIRM THAT
THE DOCUMENTATION IS VALID.
ONCE THIS BILL BECOMES LAW A
FAMILY WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
CERTIFIED ONE TIME AND BE
ELIGIBLE. FOR MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING OURS. I'M WITH THE BE
ABLE USE THAT THIRD OF THE- AT
PROOF OF THE ALLEGED. I EVEN
BEGIN TO TELL YOU HOW HELPFUL
THIS WOULD BE TO OUR FAMILIES.
ARE LOW INCOME FAMILIES OF
COLOR FACE MORE OBSTACLES THAN
MANY OF US REALIZE. THE TIME IT
TAKES TO GATHER ALL THE
DOCUMENTS NEEDED DELAYED
SERVICES THAT THEY AND THEIR
CHILDREN SO DESPERATELY NEED.
IN ADDITION THE EXTENSION OF
THEIR ELIGIBILITY TO TWENTY
FOUR MONTH PERIOD WOULD ALSO
GREATLY HELP THE FAMILIES
ACCESS AND MAINTAIN THEIR
SERVICES. THIS WOULD PROVIDE
STABILITY FOR BOTH THE FAMILY
AND THE CHILDREN WHO WOULD NO
LONGER HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
WHERE THEY WERE GOING TO GET
CARE OR WORRY ABOUT LOSING
THEIR CARE. AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
BOTH OF THESE CHANGES WOULD
ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT
PROGRAMS LIKE MINE AS WELL.
SAVING HOURS OF CLERICAL WORK
IN ADMINISTRATIVE TIME AND
DOLEFUL IMPROVING PARENT
PROGRAM RELATIONSHIP. FINALLY
EXPANDING PPD INCLUDE CHILDREN
STARTING AT EIGHTEEN MONTHS OLD
IS ANOTHER WAY TO HELP THE
FAMILIES ACCESS SERVICES.
FAMILIES WOULD BENEFIT FROM
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THEIR YOUNG
CHILDREN PLEASE SUMMARIZING
CONTRACT. YES I PLEDGE TO FIND
THAT THE COUPLE THE WAY THE SB
FIFTY WOULD REMOVE FOR FAMILIES
AND PROVIDE WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF YOUNG CHILDREN
PASSING SB FIFTY WOULD
ULTIMATELY ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO
SERVE MORE CHILDREN IN QUALITY
PRO. YOU STRENGTHENED. THANK
GOOD JOB GOOD JOB TO RETORT YOU
HAVEN'T YOU HAVE ANOTHER
WITNESS I BELIEVE YEAH. THIS
MOVIE I BILLION. YES GOOD
O'DONNELL AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS NINA CRISTIAN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AVERAGE HOW
CALIFORNIA A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
SIXTEEN HUNDRED EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROVIDERS WERE ALSO A
CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL SB FIFTY
WOULD STRENGTHEN THE SUBSIDIZED
IT WITH THEM AND ENABLE
PROVIDERS TO BETTER SERVE THE
NEEDS OF OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ESPECIALLY TODDLERS
WHICH IS WHERE WE SEE THE
GREATEST UNMET NEEDS. WE KNOW
THAT QUALITY CHILDCARE DURING
THE EARLIEST YEARS OF BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT SUCH A STRONG
FOUNDATION FOR FUTURE LEARNING
AND SIX THAT THERE'S A LARGE
UNMET NEED WHEN IT COMES TO
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS ACCORDING TO THE EARLY
LEARNING CARE MASTER PLAN ONLY
ONE IN FIVE CHILDREN WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE AND ENROLLED IN THE
STATE'S WEBSITE. SURE THE MORE
THE CURRENT SYSTEM OF
SUBSIDIZED EARLY LEARNING A
CARRIAGE OVERLY COMPLEX AND
UNCOORDINATED SB FIFTY TRIED TO
REMEDY THIS ISSUE BY REMOVING
BARRIERS FOR PROGRAMS AND
FAMILIES AT THE PREVIOUS
WITNESS MAJORITY STATED
ADDITIONALLY SB FIFTY WOULD
OPEN UP THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM TO SERVE CHILDREN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO FIVE YEARS
RATHER THAN ONLY THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS- THIS WOULD PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY TO SERVE YOUNGER
CHILDREN ONCE THEY SERVE ALL
ELIGIBLE THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS. AND I SOMETIMES CONTACT
NEEDS DON'T ALWAYS MATCH THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITIES OF
FAMILIES BY PROVIDING THE
FLEXIBILITY TO SERVE YOUNGER
CHILDREN- ABOUT MAINTAINING
QUALITY TITLE FIVE STANDARDS IN
AGE APPROPRIATE RATIOS IT WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL PROGRAMS TO
FULLY EXPAND OUR CONTACTS AND
SERVE THE CHILDREN IN OUR
COMMUNITY. SB FIFTY ALSO ALLOWS
PROVIDERS TO BE REIMBURSED
BASED ON CHILD INVOLVEMENT
RATHER THAN ATTENDANCE
PROVIDING MORE STABILITY AND
ENABLING PROVIDERS TO FULLY
UTILIZE THEIR CONTRACT FUNDS TO
SERVE CHILDREN RATHER THAN
RETURNING FUNDS TO THE STATE
ADDITIONALLY SB FIFTY WOULD
ALLOW FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO SERVE CHILDREN AND
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS WHICH
WE THINK IS A HUGE OPPORTUNITY
COULD PROVIDE MORE CHOICES FOR
PARENTS I'M MORE STABILITY FOR
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS-
ADDITIONALLY AS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY THERE'S CATEGORICAL
ELIGIBILITY WHICH MAKES IT
EASIER. FOR FAMILIES AND
PROVIDERS BY REDUCING BURKE IN
SOME PAPERWORK BUT HAD.
ELIGIBLE AND LYFT BUT NOT LEAST
SB FIFTY AFTER A MORE EQUITABLE
SYSTEM WERE MADE INCOME WORKING
FOR. CAN TWENTY MONTHS. FOR
CHILD CARE. SO THE THEY
CONTINUE TO WORK CHILDREN BE IN
A STATE HIGH. AND FOR THESE
REASONS URGE YOUR- FOR. FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE A
THERE'S NO OPPOSITE- WHAT WILL
DO NOW IS WILL GO TO THE- THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
MISTER MCCARTY MISTER MISTER
CHILD CARE RIGHT THERE- CHILD-
WHAT EARLY AND GUY GO FOR. PRE
K. EARLY AT EARLY LEARNING IT'S
ALL GOOD IT'S ALL MCCARTY NO I
DON'T FEEL EVERYBODY IN THIS IS
THIS THAT THE POINT IS THIS IS
PART OF A- OF A PACKAGE OF
MEASURES. AND BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS WHICH WILL
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE ACCESS
FOR NOT JUST PRE K. FOR FOUR
YEAR OLDS THROUGH TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN BUT FOR ZERO THREE
THREE AND THIS IS A PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE. AND I THINK ONE KEY
POINT TWO IS TOO OFTEN YOU KNOW
IT'S HARD FOR PARENTS TAKE.
THEIR INCOME ELIGIBLE BUT WE
MAKE HIM GET THIS FORM AND THAT
FORM LAST YEAR TAP TAXES. AND
POVERTY IS POVERTY IS VERY-
CONFINEMENT AND WE'RE OUT OF
WAYS TO SHOW. YOUR INCOME AND
YOUR AND YOUR- WORTHINESS FOR
DC AND THIS REDUCES THOSE
BARRIERS AND SO I THINK THIS IS
KATIE AND- I'M OF THE BILL
THANK YOU SENATOR LIMA THANK
YOU. SECOND THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU SEE NO FOR COMMENT
PERMITTED THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OTHERS THANK YOU FOR THE BILL.
AND YOUR ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN. CHILD
CARE IS A BIG EAL. YES THERE
IS I JUST GRABBED MY LITTLE ONE
OFF AT HOW DID YOU DO IT RIGHT
AND IT'S NOT EASY TO DO NUMBER
ONE IT IS NOT EASY TO PAY FOR.
IT AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE-
YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE
TODAY SO THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT- WITH THAT WE WILL GO TO
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE ROOM.
SINGLE PUBLIC COMING IN THE
ROOM. WE'LL GO TO THE CAPITAL
PARK. STATION I DON'T SEE ANY.
BODY ON THE CAPITOL PARK.
REMOTE S. WILL GO TO THE
PHONES- TEN MINUTES SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PHONES OUR
MODERATOR PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
IF SO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
WELL FIRST SCORELINE OF FORTY
TWO. CARADON WHERE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE PATTY HER ON
BEHALF OF EARLY EDGE CALIFORNIA
A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF SB FIFTY
IN SUPPORT. NEXT WOULD ALIGN
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORAYSHIRE ABOUT THE NUMBERS
MANY LUXURY GOODS FROM
EDUCATION TRUST WEST SUPPORT
BILL. LINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES WITH THE STICKER
C. ON BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT. IN LINE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CALLING BACKGROUND
BEHALF BUT THE ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE COURT.
M. LINE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR NUMBERS LISTA PARA
EVENTS ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINES OPEN. THANK YOU DON'T
HAVE TO THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT. LINE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING WHICH ALSO
PREVENTS K<c.cyan> OF KIDDING NO</c>
PRACTICAL SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
LINE THIRTY BECAUSE I HAD. GOOD
MORNING CARE MEMBERS LESLIE
VASQUEZ WITH THE LEGAL WOMEN
VOTERS THE CALIFORNIA IMPORT
THANK YOU. LINED ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LARA MACINNES START
YOUR- COMMUNITY CHILD CARE
COUNCIL OF CINEMA COUNTY AND
NORTHERN DIRECTORS GROUP IN
SUPPORT. NINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING AND
TAKE THAT RIGHTFUL WITH THE
DANIEL UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. LATITUDE
LINE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER
WITH THAT YEAH YOU WERE A
LITTLE BIT BETWEEN- WE HAVE
SOME CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED YOU WERE DISAPPOINTED
THE- THE AMENDMENT PROPOSED
ELIMINATED THE RT HE WE CAN
THAT IMPORTANT INVESTMENT
PROCESS AS WELL THE
STREAMLINING FACTORS ULTIMATELY
REJECTING THAT THIS IS A NEW
PROPOSAL THAT WILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT AN IMPLANT.
THANK YOU FATHER THANK YOU
PLEASE MOVE ON. AND THEN
FURTHER IN Q. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY OKAY ARE WITH THAT- YOU
MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE OKAY THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL SENATE AGAIN- DO
WE HAVE A- IT'S MOVED BY MR
MCCARTY. SECONDLY MISTER
BENNETT AND- WELL- GO AHEAD OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YEAH I DID YEAH YEAH THIS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I
DON'T KNOW I KILEY KILEY AYE
SENATE SENATE I DAILY DALLY
I'LL LEAVE MCCARTY HI MCCARTY I
QUIT SILVA. RICK SILVA I SIX
THE BILL HAS SIX WHAT IS IT IS
A COMMUNITY WHERE MEN COULD
WORK THANK YOU. FOR YOU WERE
WAITING. FOR SENATOR LEYVA
WHERE ARE YOU PORTANTINO. BUT
CHAU IS CENTER YEAH. OKAY.
RICHARD ON HER WAY. I HAVE BEEN.
NINE FILE ITEM NINE NEXT ITEM
IS FILE ITEM NINE. THAT IS SB.
SEVEN TWO FIVE. WE WILL DO
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF A LUXURY.
DISTURBIA. READ OUT HER PHONE
TO SEE. THEY'REONE YEAH OKAY.
OKAY VIGORA. I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE- A COUPLE OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT TRIED TO GET
IN TO TESTIFIED BUT WERE
BLOCKED BY THE AT&T SYSTEM FROM
TESTIFYING- THEIR NAMES ARE
COULD VIDA- MEDALLIA THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF THE DEATH- DEATH
OF THEIR POSITION IS NEUTRAL-
THANK YOU ALSO ROSE A BARREL.
AG BAYANI PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA HANDS AND VOICES
PARENT ORGANIZATION- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR EFFORTS TODAY AND WE
APOLOGIZE THAT YOU GOT DROPPED
FROM THE SYSTEM ON THE PHONE.
AND AGAIN IT WAS A LITTLE THE
RELATED TO MR COURT. THAT WAS
RELATED MISTER CORTESE'S BILL
SB.
SIX NINE TWO. THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY HAPPEN IN. WE.
THANK YOU. YEAH. AT SENATE BILL.
YEAH. YEAH I MEAN. SENATOR
WELCOME WE'VE BEEN AWAITING
YOUR ARRIVAL. YOU'RE HAPPY
YOU'RE HERE YOU MAY PROCEED.
RECEIVE AVAILABLE NINE SB SEVEN
TWO FIVE. YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER TERRY MEMBERS
THANK YOU MY FIRST TIME HERE SO
VERY EXCITED. TO BE HERE WITH
YOU BEFORE I BEGIN I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME AT AND AMENDMENTS HI
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THEM AS
NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
SO THANK YOU. SB SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE PROVIDES A DEFINITION OF
PARENT PARTICIPATION PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS SHE DIED LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES IN CREATING
YOU ARE SUPPORTING EXISTING
PARENT PARTICIPATION PRESCHOOL.
PARENT PARTICIPATION PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE NATION HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO DEVELOP STRONG BONDS
BETWEEN PARENTS AND CHILDREN
AND GIVE PARENTS THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL PARENTS.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
PARENT TEACHER ASSOCIATION WHEN
FAMILIES ARE INVOLVED IN THEIR
CHILDREN'S EDUCAR EN AT SCHOOL
THEIR CHILDREN DO BETTER IN
SCHOOL. AND RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT THERE IS. THAT THERE IS A
POSITIVE AND CONVINCING
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN FAMILY
INVOLVEMENT AND SUCCESS
REGARDLESS OF RACE ETHNICITY
CLASS OR PARENTS LEVEL OF
EDUCATION. SB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY SUPPORT PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO HELP PARENTS AND
CARE GIVERS LEARN HOW TO
SUPPORT THEIR CHILD'S LEARNING
AND DEVELOPMENT THROUGH THE
PARENTS PARTICIPATION IN THE
CLASSROOM AND THROUGH
EDUCATIONAL CLASSES FOR THE
PARENTS. THESE PROGRAMS HELP
PARENTS GAIN REAL LIFE SKILLS
AND STRATEGIES FOR PARENTING
YOUNG CHILDREN IT INITIATES
FAMILY INVOLVEMENT AND CONNECTS
PARENTS WITH THEIR LOCAL SCHOOL
COMMUNITY AT THE EARLIEST
STAGES. SB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
ALSO INCLUDES A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE RESULT OF
THE PILOT PROGRAM BEFORE
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR THREE EVALUATE THE IMPACT
OF THE PROGRAM I'M COMMUNITIES.
ALTHOUGH WE DO NOT HAVE A LEAD
WITNESS KIM BUSKIRK AND TAMERA
TOBY WHO ARE FORMER AND CURRENT
PARENT PARTICIPATION PROGRAM
TEACHERS ARE ON THE LINE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT DURING THE
TIME PERMITTED. THANK YOU. THAT
WOULD. OKAY ARE YOU SAYING YOU
HAVE WITNESSES BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THEM HERE YES WE DON'T
HAVE- LEAD WITNESSES- WE
ACTUALLY DID NOT HAVE BEEN THE
ENTIRE THE TESTIFYING FOR TWO
MILLENNIA YES THEY ARE THE TIME
ALLOTTED WHO WHO ARE THEY- SO
THEY- ARE. KIM BUSKIRK AND
TAMERA TOBI HER FORMER AND
CURRENT PARENT PARTICIPATION
PROGRAM TEACHERS- ONE SECOND
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T GET APPROVAL
FOR THAT SO ME JUST CHECK ONE
THING. SIX OF THEM. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA LET YOU YOU GOT TO
WITNESSES YES CORRECT K. THAT
SEEMS LIKE THERE WAS A
BREAKDOWN BECAUSE WE NEED TO
APPROVE THOSE BEFORE THEY DO
TESTIFIED TODAY ONE OF WHAT YOU
DO IS A LET'S GO AHEAD WITH
YOUR TWO WITNESSES FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH EACH WITNESS I'M
ASSUMING THEY CAN HEAR ME RIGHT
NOW WILL WILL WILL- GO FOR TWO
MINUTES. AND AGAIN THE FUTURE
WE JUST NEED TO HAVE BETTER
COMMUNICATION SO WE KNOW WHO
THE WITNESSES ARE AND I THANK
YOU FOR THAT SO TO YOUR FOR
YOUR FIRST WITNESSES FROM HIM
BUSKIRK. OKAY SO. YOU'RE WOULD
FIRST WITNESS MAY PROCEED. SO
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT IN THE
SYSTEM OKAY TAMERA WHEN WE DO
THIS WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL GO
TO THE FOLLOWING WHEN WE GO TO
THE PHONES IF YOUR WITNESSES
ARE ON THOSE PHONES WE WILL LET
THEM HAVE TWO MINUTES OKAY OKAY
I ISSUE THERE BUT THEY'RE NOT
THE SYSTEM- THEY'RE NOT QUEUED
UP TO TESTIFY AS WITNESSES
BECAUSE- THEY WERE. WE DIDN'T
KNOW WHO THEY WERE. TESTIFYING
UNDER PUBLIC COMMENTS IN THERE.
THEY WERE NOT GIVEN TO US AS
PRIMARY WITNESSES. OKAY HOUSE
BEGAN OKAY BUT SHE WISHES TO
HAVE THEM TEST- AS PRIMARY WAS
JUST SO WHEN WE GO TO THE
PHONES. WE'LL DO IS WE'LL LET
THEM. TESTIFIES PRIMARY
WITNESSES NOT NOT A NOT A
PROBLEM AWARD. LETTERS
CONVENIENCE. SO WITH THAT- WHEN
WE GO TO THE FRONT OF THAT SO-
OF ANY- SO THERE'S NO- NO
OFFICE AND ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WISH TO COMMENT. A
SENIOR CONFIRMATION THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL NOW GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE ROOM.
NO PERSONS ARE IN THE ROOM TO
TESTIFY WE'LL GO TO THE CAPITOL
PARK. NOBODY IN CAPITOL PARK
AND WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES-
ARE AND IF YOUR WITNESSES ARE
THERE THEY MAY TAKE NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES- FOR THOSE TWO
WITNESSES ONLY WHO HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY YOU. SO TO THE
PHONES MODERATOR PLEASE. HE
REMARKED IT IS ONE AND THEN
THERE OUGHT TO HAVE YOUR LINE
OPEN I DO HAVE ONE IN Q. WILL
GO TO LINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SEVEN YEAR NINE.
SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AB CAPTURE MUTISM. I ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE AN ADULT LEVEL ONE
CHEWING UP YOUR PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. A LINE OF SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU SAID
SEVENTY SIX THAT'S ME- I AM KIM
BUSKIRK I WAS THE- THE PURCHASE
INTENT AND YOU KIND OF- BUT
DISSIPATION PROGRAM MY- I WENT
THERE WITH ALL THREE OF MY
DAUGHTERS. AND THEN I BECAME
THE TEACHER OF THAT FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. I LOVE THE PROGRAM
IT HELPED ME SO MUCH WITH. IN
MY OWN CHILDREN AS WELL AS I
SAW FIRST HAND HOW IT HELPS THE
FAMILIES IN OUR COMMUNITY. YOU
KNOW WHAT THE CHALLENGES OF
PARENTING THERE IS NO-
INSTRUCTION MANUAL SO PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS HELP PARENTS
NAVIGATE. THROUGH THE FORMATIVE
YEARS OF CHILDREN- YOU KNOW HOW
TO HANDLE DIFFERENT SITUATIONS-
AFFECTED. GRAHAM WAS WHAT IT
WAS CALLED IN YUCAIPA SCHOOL
DISTRICT- WAS THE MAINSTAY OF
OUR COMMUNITY IT LASTED FOR.
FORTY YEARS BEFORE- COALBED
ENDED IT- AND I JUST SAW THE
VALUE OF THE PROGRAM AND THE
SUPPORT IT HAD HELPING YOUNG
FAMILIES THRIVE IN MANY CASES
THE PROGRAM WAS THE FIRST STEP
FOR PARENTS IN THE EDUCATION TO
THEIR- FOR THEIR CHILD INTO
THEIR CHILD'S EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESS I FEEL THAT GROWING
FAMILIES OF TODAY NEEDS MORE
SUPPORT NAVIGATING THROUGH THE
PRESSURES AND CHALLENGES OF
RAISING THEIR CHILDREN THEN
LEFT SUPPORT I FEEL THAT THE
PARENT PARTICIPATION PROGRAM.
S. B. SEVEN TWENTY FIVE WOULD
BE A HUGE BENEFIT TO ALL THE
COMMUNITIES. AND THE YOUNG
FAMILIES IN THAT AREA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO OUR NEXT
PERSON ON THE PHONE. IT WILL
MOVE ON TO THE LINE OF SEVENTY
FIVE KIDS BUT HAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TAMARA TOBY
AND I AM A PARENT PARTICIPATION
PRESCHOOL TEACHER. I AM IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE. RESULT YES WE'RE SUPPORT
OF THIS AND YOU TWENTY FIVE
BELL- I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL OVER MY
CAREER I HAVE WORKED IN HEAD
START HOT. EDUCATION WORK WITH
THE PS. ADMINISTERED
DEVELOPMENT SACRAMENTO COTTON
AND OTHER PRESCHOOL SETTING.
FOR THE PAST TWELVE YEARS I'VE
BEEN WORKING AND I CAN'T
EDUCATION PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
THAT HAS DIVIDE THAT CAN
DAMAGE. AND HAS. BEEN AROUND
SINCE NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT.
BURKE IN THE CREEK CLASS SKILLS
TO HELP CHILDREN THOUGH COUNTY
SKILL SECOND. AT TABLE. TO
PARENTS THAT JUGGLING WHICH
MASS WILL. I WANT. OUR. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THE OPTION. I'M
NOT. GOING THANK YOU YOUR BOOK.
THEY YOU TO THE NEXT IT OTHER
WITNESS ON PERSONS WHICH SURE
OPINION ON THE PHONE. IT
CURRENTLY NINE AND- THANK YOU.
ARE WE THAT- SENATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER CHAIR JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I WAS PERSONALLY
ADVERTISEMENT ONE OF THESE
PROGRAMS WITH MY THREE CHILDREN
AND I CAN TESTIFY TO YOU OF THE
IMMENSE HELP THAT IT GAVE ME
EVEN AS A COLLEGE GRADUATE
HAVING GONE THROUGH MY TEACHING
CREDENTIAL COURSES AND SO FORTH
THAT THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
PROGRAM AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MANY
OF OUR FAMILIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TO PRESENT SB
SEVEN TWENTY FIVE WHEN PARENTS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES WORK
TOGETHER EVERYONE BENEFITS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR
ANY TIME WE- ENCOURAGE PARENT
PARTICIPATION IN A CHILD'S
EDUCATION IT'S A VERY GOOD
THING WITH VERY GOOD OUTCOME SO
THANK YOU WITH THAT- DO WE HAVE
A MOTION SOME OF. IT'S BEEN%
MOVED AND SECONDED THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL. I DONNA I'D KILEY
KILEY AYE BENNETT. DALLI DALLI
I'D LEAVE MCCARTY HI MCCARTY I
QUICK SILVA. QUICKSILVER I.
BILL IS FIVE OH THAT IS A GOOD
JOB SENATOR. WITH THAT MISS
LEYVA IS IN ROUTE. JUST TAXES.
FILE AND. NINE SIX WAS FILED
SIX SB TWO FOUR SB TWO FOUR SIX
FIVE ITEMS. DO WE TO MOVE THE
CONSENT COME. OTHER OKAY LET'S
HOLD OFF AND SENATOR- S. NO
THIS IS NOT. FORTY TWO POINT
HAVE A REGISTRY UP HERE SO SB
TWO FOUR CENTER GO JOB RAN I
DID RUN FOR THE U. ONLY ONE
THAT RAN TODAY YEAH YOU KNOW.
PARDON. FIFTY FOUR. THE SAN.
ALL RIGHT ARE YOU READY CHAIR
EVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
GOODBYE MR CHU GOOD MORNING
MEMBER. SB TWO FORTY SIX THE
CHAU CARE SO OF THE RIGHT WITH
A STEP IS REGIONALI
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SYSTEM FOR
CHILD CARE PRESCHOOL AND EARLY
LEARNING SERVICES. THE
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS A
MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT
PROVIDES THESE IMPORTANT
SERVICES TO OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS IT HAS TWO SEPARATE
ADELINE SYSTEM FOR REIMBURSING
PROVIDERS THAT MEET TO
DIFFERENT STANDARDS. EXISTING
BIFURCATED SYSTEM AND IN A
QUITE INADEQUATE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES COMPLICATE EFFORTS TO
FUND TO DELIVER HIGH QUALITY
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. THAT MEET THE
DEVELOPMENT NEEDS OF ALL
CHILDREN WHILE ALSO ADDRESSING
THE HEALTH SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF THE CHILDREN BEING
SERVED. THE CENTRE LINE TO
SYSTEM APPROACH LIMITS ACCESS
BILLS TO MAXIMIZE PROGRAM
QUALITY NEWS FORCING MANY
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. OUT OF BUSINESS AS
MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW WE LOST
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS CREATED
BY THE CURRENT RATE SYSTEM
RESOURCE EXPENDITURES SHOULD BE
STREAMLINED AND EXPANDED IN THE
WAY THAT ONE. COMPENSATE
TEACHERS AND PROGRAMS FOR THE
COST OF PROVIDING CARE TO ARE
RESPONSIVE TO THE ECONOMIC
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THREE
RECOGNIZE THE COST OF MEETING
VARYING QUALITY STANDARDS AND
FOR INCENTIVIZE HIGH STANDARDS
AND PARTICIPATION IN RESEARCH
BASED. QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
EFFORTS. AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN JUST ONE IN NINE
CHILDREN ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIZED CARE IN CALIFORNIA
RECEIVE THESE SERVICES. HOWEVER
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
HIGHLIGHTED WITH THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AND I HAVE KNOWN FOR
DECADES SPECIFICALLY THAT CHILD
CARE WORKERS ARE ESSENTIAL. TO
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE TO OUR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND FOR WOMEN
TO BE FULL PARTICIPANTS IN OUR
WORKFORCE. I HAVE OPERATE
REFORM FOR THREE YEARS NOW AND
MORE THAN EVER IS THE TIME TO
RESTRUCTURE HOW WE REIMBURSE
PROVIDERS TO ALLOW THEM TO KEEP
THEIR DOORS OPEN. TO SERVE MORE
CHILDREN. WE ALL DEPEND ON THEM
DURING THE PANDEMIC. SO LONG AS
OVER DO. SO AS LONG OVERDUE
THAT WE DO THE RIGHT THING
THROUGH THESE REFORMS
CALIFORNIA CAN ACHIEVE A MORE
EQUITABLE SYSTEM TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
MAXIMIZE PUBLIC BENEFIT. I
WOULD NOW LIKE TO INTRODUCE
NEED EMPATHY WITH EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA AND MONIQUE RAMOS
WITH FIRST FIVE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL MEMBERS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. YOUR TO
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE. MORNING
MONEY GRANDMA ABOUT HALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA A CO
SPONSOR OF SB TWO FORTY SIXTH.
INFORMAL CARE THE PART OF THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE FAMILY
SELECTED THEY ARE BALANCING
WORK AND WORK AND PARENTING IN
CALIFORNIA WE REFER TO THAT
LEASES LICENSE EXAM PROVIDERS
OR FRIEND AND FAMILY NEIGHBOR
CARE. MOST PARENTS IF NOT ALL
USE THIS CARE FOR THE REGULAR
PART OF THEIR LIVES. THESE
CARETAKERS ARE OFTEN
GRANDMOTHERS AUNTS NEIGHBORS
AND FAMILY FRIENDS
UNFORTUNATELY THE SUBSIDIZE THE
STEM. HAVE THE EMBARRASSINGLY
ROAD LOW RATES FOR LICENSE EXAM
PROVIDERS THESE PROVIDERS HAVE
NOT RECEIVED A RATE INCREASE IN
THE TEN YEARS PRIOR TO THE
GREAT RECESSION AND THEN DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION FACED A 30%
REDUCTION. FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES MANY OF WHOM WORK
NONTRADITIONAL HOURS IN THE
SERVICE INDUSTRIES THESE ARE
THE ONLY CARE THAT MEETS THEIR
NEEDS. TO HIGHLIGHT ONE PROBLEM
WITH OUR CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT
RATES SYSTEM. WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT AN EXAMPLE FROM THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER. A
FULL TIME RENDON FAMILY
NEIGHBOR PROVIDER WHO PROVIDES
CARE FOR SCHOOL AGED CHILD IN
THE EVENING. IF PAID TWO
DOLLARS AND EIGHTY CENTS AN
HOUR. WE BELIEVE THESE RATES
ARE NOT ONLY UNFAIR BUT
UNSUSTAINABLE AND BY NOT
INCREASING RATES WE WILL LOSE A
NUMBER OF PROVIDERS WILLING TO
PROVIDE CARE STEPS THAT
FAMILIES WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
REIMBURSEMENT RATE REFORM
IMPROVISE IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
ALL PROVIDERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TO THE NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN NO DIALOGUE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AGAIN MY NAME
IS NINA THINKING THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
SIXTEEN HUNDRED EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROVIDERS ALSO A
PROUD CO SPONSOR SB TWO FOUR
SIX AS OUTLINED AND THREE TWO
FOUR SIX OFFER SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS THE BIFURCATED RATE
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM N
CALIFORNIA. CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA HAS TO BREAK THIS
DOWN FOR SOME SITES EARLY
LEARNING CARE PROGRAMS THE XR
OR THE STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT
RATE WHICH IS ONE STEP RIGHT
ACROSS THE STATE AND THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE WHICH
ACCOUNTS. FOR SOME GEOGRAPHIC
AND REGIONAL CALL. OKAY CAN
ACCOUNT SERVICES AS OUR CHILL
SIR LITTLE. BIT BY OKAY SISTER
COMPLICATES REIMBURSED SYSTEM.
I S. R. IS ONE WHERE ADJUSTED
FOR. WELL R. MARGARITA RIGHT
WITH NO. ADJUSTMENT WE ARE
TRYING TO CONFRONT SIMPLE THE
POP AND- A- RATE THAT WOULD BE
MORE AFFORDABLE PROVIDERS AND
FAMILIES. THIS NEW RATE
STRUCTURE WILL INCLUDE ALLSTATE
SUBSIDIZED PROGRAMS THE
FOUNDATION OF WHICH IS MODERN
FATHER MODERNIZED STRUCTURE IS
CALLED THE BASE RATE. WHEN
FULLY PHASED IN THE BASEMENT
WILL WILL REPLACE BOTH THE
EXIST RATE STRUCTURES AND WILL
BE APPLIED TO ALL PROGRAM
TYPES. THE BASE RATE WILL BE
ADJUSTED FOR MARKETS AND
BALANCE REFLECT DIFFERENT COST
OF LIVING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
FOR LIKE THE PROGRAM YEAR FOR
PROVIDER TYPE HOURS OF SERVICE
AND CHARACTERISTIC OF CHILDREN
SERVED. THE BASE RATE IS
CONSISTENT WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY
EDUCATION AND WILL BE INCREASE
ANNUALLY. THE NEW REIMBURSEMENT
RATE WILL ALSO INCENTIVIZE
QUALITY AND PARTICIPATION IN
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES THROUGH
A QUALITY FACTOR. THIS WILL
ENCOURAGE ALL PROVIDERS
REGARDLESS OF PROGRAM TYPE
BETWEEN RICH THAT PROGRAMMING
ENVIRONMENTS AND PAY FOR THE
INCREASED COSTS AND FEES AFTER
SIX BLOCKS TO THE FULLEST I
WISH I KNEW CRISIS FACTOR WHICH
CAN BE USED TO DISTRIBUTE
SPONSORED CHILD CARE. EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS SERVING
CHILDREN IN THE COUNTY
EXPERIENCING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. THIS MECHANISM CAN
BE USED ON A COUNTY BY COUNTY
OR STATEWIDE BASIS WHEN A STATE
OF EMERGENCY AT THE CLARIDGE
SAYS THAT SUCH AS WILD FIRES
EARTHQUAKES EXCEPT TRAP. THIS
WOULD BE A SHORT TERM
ADJUSTMENT FOR THE DURATION OF
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS NEW RATE
STRUCTURE PLEASE SUMMARIZE OF
SIZE REIMBURSEMENT RATE SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA. ALLOWING FOR
UNIFIED WHAT LITTLE APPROACH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SENATOR
LABOR HER FOR HER SUPPORT I
URGE. AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE WITH THERE ARE
OFFICES WENT AS WERE THE CA
MEMBERS THE QUESTION REMAIN IN
THE MEMBER. I MISSED. THE BILL
NEXT AND THEN JUST ADD A FEW
COMMENTS. YEAH THIS IS AS SAID
THIS IS BEEN A LONG. IN THE
MAKING I KNOW YOU AT THIS. OUT
FOR AWHILE IN A BUDGET
COMMITTEE MR THE WE'VE-
INCREASE LOTS A NUMBER TIMES
OVER THE YEARS WHAT THINGS YOU.
YOU CAN LOTS ALL YOU WANT IF
YOU DON'T HAVE THE- COURSE RATE
THEY DON'T PENCE OUT THE- YOU
KNOW WE'VE INCREASE MINIMUM
WAGES IN CALIFORNIA AND SORRY
COULD WE PAY. TOO OFTEN POVERTY
WAGES FOR THESE WORKERS AND YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TURNOVER AND SO
FORTH SO THIS HAS BEEN. AN
ISSUE THAT WAS- DOCUMENTED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S MASTER PLAN OUR
ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION. AND AGAINST LIKE
THE LIMóN BELT TWENTY MINUTES
AGO. THIS IS PART OF OUR
OVERALL PUZZLED TO REALLY-
DRAMATICALLY. INCREASE ACCESS
AND AFFORDABILITY FOR EARLY
CHAIR EARLY CARE EDUCATION
CHILD CARE AND OUR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS BENEFIT FROM
THESE RATES TO SELL. FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS LICENSE
EXAM. SCHOOL DISTRICTS THEY ALL
WOULD WOULD BENEFIT AND- LASTLY
THIS IS THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM AS WE KNOW WITH THE BUDGET
WE HAVEN'T FINALIZED WITH THE
GOVERNOR YET WE PUT MONEY. IN
THE BUDGET FOR THIS BUT WE NEED
THIS BILL AND DOOR A COMPANION
TRAILER BILL AUTHORIZES TO
HAPPEN SO. THIS THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN SO THANK YOU SIR LEYVA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
BENNETT OUR BUSINESS MISTER
BENNETT. THAT'S JUST A GOOD
BILL REALLY APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT AND CERTAINLY. VERY
NEEDED THANK YOU. SCORSONE YES
I WANT TO THANK THE SENATE FOR
WORK THIS SPACE AS WE HAS
ALREADY BEEN SAID IN THE YOU
KNOW SOME OF OUR NEIGHBORS THAT
LIVE IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE
MIGHT JUST ASSUME THEY COULD
JUST GO TO A PRESCHOOL THE
LOCAL PRESCHOOL THE LOCAL
CHURCH ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
WAYS TO TAKE CARE OF CHILDREN
AND YET FOR SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE WORKERS THAT IS NOT
AN OPTION- ALSO WHEN YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE CHILDREN. WOULD WHICH
I HAD FOR YOUNG CHILDREN AT THE
SAME TIME TO VERY CLOSE IN AGE
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WELL
OVER A THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH
JUST ON CHILD CARE. THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY EXPO IN PART AND TO
NOT ONLY HAVE ACCESS TO CHILD
CARE BUT ALSO TO HAVE CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS THAT ARE HIGH
QUALITY- I HAVE A COMPANION
BILL WITH ALTERNATIVE. PAYMENT
AND I THINK BOTH OF THESE BILLS
I'M HOPING THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
TEAM IS LISTENING TODAY THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND JUST HOW VITAL
THESE. ISSUES ARE TO GET PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK IN CHILDREN TAKEN
CARE OF IN A SAFE WAY THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
COMMENT FOR MANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE WILL GO IN THE ROOM
ANY PERSONS IN THE ROOM WHICH
TESTIFIED. SAYING NONE OF THE
ROOM WILL GO TO THE CAPITOL
PARK SEEING NONE THERE WILL GO
TO THE PHONES IF YOU'RE ON THE
PHONES AND YOU WISH TO SHARE
YOUR OPINION ONLY- YOU MAY
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
POLICE TO THE PHONES TEN
MINUTES- MODERATOR PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN NUMBERS CAPPING
VAN OSTERN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. NINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M REPLICATED GARCIA
ON BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT. AN EIGHTY
TWO YEAR LINE IS OPEN. HEALTH
OR PREVENT KEY WITH KATANGA IN
SUPPORT. NINE EIGHTY FOUR YEAR
OPEN. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS DIDN'T COME OUT ON FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LOCATED PAYMENT
PROGRAM SUBSTATION IN STRONG
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CALLING BACKGROUND
BEHALF LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND PART. SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EBONY
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
SAN MATTEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES NEKRON WILL BE HALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY DISTRICT
ADVOCATES FOR BETTER SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT. NINE THIRTY YOUR OPEN.
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JESSICA PARKER ON BEHALF
OF CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE ELSE ONE
SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING NAY RODRIGUEZ FROM
EDUCATION PROPUESTAS COOPER.
NINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE I'M GLAD TO
HEAR YOUR ANSWER. HI THIS IS
WHAT THE DOCTORS OF THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AT THIS TIME NO ONE ELSE
HAS SIGNALED THEY WISH TO SPEAK
GREAT THANK YOU ARE YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOUR YEAR ON THE SUPPORTIVE
COMMENTS- WE NEED TO DO RATE
REFORM. THEN WE NEED SLOTS AND
THEN WE CAN START TO THINK
ABOUT T. K. MEMBERS 98% OF THE
PEOPLE IN AREN'T WORKING OR DAY
CARE CENTERS AND OUR PREACH AT
PRESCHOOL CENTERS ARE WOMEN.
56% ARE WOMEN OF COLOR A 100%
OUR FUTURE LEADERS THE CHILDREN
THAT THEY ARE TAKING CARE OF.
THERE'S AN OLD SAYING THAT SAYS
DON'T TELL ME WHAT YOUR
PRIORITIES ARE SHOW ME WHERE
YOU SPEND YOUR MONEY AND I'LL
TELL YOU WHERE YOUR PRIORITIES
LIE. I THINK IT'S TIME THAT WE
IN CALIFORNIA SHOW THE WOMEN
AND THE CHILDREN OF THE STATE
THAT WE PRIORITIZE THEM.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU- IT HAS
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ALREADY- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST YOU
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI
LADONNA ARE A KILEY KILEY AYE
BENNETT AYE FINANCE AYE DALLY.
DALLI I. LI LI I MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE CORK SILVA.
QUICKSILVER HI SEVEN SIX IT HAS
IT HAS VOTED HUMBOLDT SEVEN.
SEVEN SEVEN OKAY SEVEN VOTES. I
CAN SING SIX BUT THERE IS
ACTUALLY SEVEN- BOB. AT THE
REGISTER TO THANK YOU MEMBERS
YOU LIST THE CONSENT QUICK. AND
PLEASE OKAY OF. UP TO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MR MCCARTY MOVES MISTER LEE
SECONDS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
FILE ITEM THREE SB SEVEN OH
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM FOR SB
THREE NINETY THREE AT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. FILE ITEM FIVE
SB FOUR HUNDRED THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. FILE ITEM EIGHT
SB SEVEN TWENTY TO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. FILE ITEM
TWELVE SB NINETY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE DONALD BY
DONALD HI KILEY KILEY I'VE
SENATE SENATE HI DALLI DALLY
I'LL LEAVE. LEE I'VE MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE CORK SILVA. SIX OF
THE SIX WORDS WITHOUT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT THANK
YOU. WE'RE GONNA MOVE THE FILE
ITEM TEN FIRST FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN. SB FOURTEEN PHONE NUMBER
TEN MISTER PORTANTINO THANK YOU
FOR WAITING HEN. AND BEING HERE
IN A TIMELY FASHION WE'VE DONE
SOME WAITING TODAY BUT NOT FOR
YOURSELF THANK YOU YOU MAY
PERCEIVE AN ARRAY I DO THE BEST
I CAN THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING-
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
US SENATORS DODD HUESO PAN
RUBIO NUMBER. AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS LOW POWER QUE
HAN CHAO CUNNINGHAM AND LEE
MAIENSCHEIN AND CORK SILVA FOR
BEING CO AUTHORS OF S. B.
FOURTEEN. WHICH I BELIEVE IS A
CRITICAL BILL TO HELP OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE. TO DEAL WITH THAT.
AFTER EFFECTS OF THE PANDEMIC
AND CONTINUING MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS. CALIFORNIA IS IN THE
MIDST OF THE YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CRISIS EXACERBATED BY
COVERT NINETEEN. WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING OUR YOUTH ARE
INCREASINGLY ISOLATED AND
DISENGAGED WITH DEPRESSION
SYMPTOMS. AT ALL AT AN ALL TIME
HIGH FOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT%
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
NEARLY ONE IN THREE CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS SURVEYED.
REPORTED FEELING SAD OR
HOPELESS ALMOST EVERY DAY. TWO
OR MORE WEEKS IN A ROW NEARLY
ONE IN FIVE REPORTED THAT THEY
HAVE SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED
ATTEMPTING SUICIDE. TEACHERS
AND SCHOOL STAFF FROM THE FRONT
LINES OF THIS CRISIS AND SHOULD
BE TRAINED TO IDENTIFY AND HELP
STUDENTS WHO ARE SUFFERING.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE SOONER
PEOPLE GET HELP FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
CONCERNS. THE MORE LIKELY THEY
ARE TO HAVE A POSITIVE OUTCOME.
I SCHOOLS BEGINS TRANSITION
INTO TO IN PERSON LEARNING IN A
FEW MONTHS TEACHERS ARE BOUND
TO BE FACED WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES RESULTING FROM.
THE EMOTIONAL IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC ON THEIR STUDENTS SB
FOURTEEN WOULD HELP ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM- EVER AS A READ
FIRST. THE WHAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY IN SHORT THAT STUDENTS
ABSENCES FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONCERNS ARE DEALT WITH ON PAR.
WITH THE WAY SCHOOLS EXCUSE
ABSENCES FOR PHYSICAL HEALTH AS
ORIGINALLY DRAFTED THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE SPOKEN DIRECTLY TO
THE NEED OF MANY SCHOOL
PERSONNEL WHO COULD BENEFIT
FROM TRAINING. FOR IDENTIFY YOU
THROUGHOUT THAT HAVE A BIGGER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
MAKE APPROPRIATE REFERRALS SO
THEY COULD GET THE HELP THEY
NEED. A SIMILAR VERSION OF THIS
BILL THAT WAS PROPOSED PRIOR TO
PANDEMIC MADE IT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK. WITH THE
REQUIREMENT FOR TEACHERS TO BE
TRAINED. SO WHY PUSH FORWARD
WITHOUT THAT YOU KNOW FRANKLY.
EVERY STEP FORWARD. IS
INCREMENTAL TOWARDS DEEPENING
THE STIGMATIZING MENTAL HEALTH
BUT I ALSO THINK OF THE FATHER
WHO CALLED IN TO TESTIFY WHEN I
PRESENTED THIS BILL AND SENATE
EDUCATION ABOUT HIS DAUGHTER
WHO TURNED IN HER JOURNALIST
SIMON. GOT A GRADE AND I TOOK
HER OWN LIFE. THE FATHER DIDN'T
BLAME THE TEACHER FOR NOT
SEEING THE SIDES OF SUICIDE.
BECAUSE HE RECOGNIZED THAT THE
TEACHER WAS NOT TRAINED TO
RECOGNIZE THEM. FRANKLY I
BELIEVE THAT THAT TRAINING WILL
SAVE LIVES MEMBERS WE HAVE TO
LOOK BEYOND THE POLITICS AND
FIND SOLUTIONS FOR YOUTH WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING A BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CRISIS. BY LEGALIZED
FIGHT WITH LEGALIZING. MENTAL
HEALTH ABSENCES AND REQUIRING
CD TO IDENTIFY THE BEST
PRACTICES AND TRAINING FOR
SCHOOL PERSONNEL. WE'RE TAKING
A STEP FORWARD. AS I'VE SAID I
THINK WE CAN DO BETTER. THIS
BILL IS SPONSORED BY A
COALITION OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCATES WHO HAVE TIRELESSLY
WORKED TO ILLUSTRATE THE NEED
FOR TEACHER TRAINING. LED BY
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES AND
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION LADY GAGA'S BORN
THIS WAY FOUNDATION. DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA AND IMPORTANTLY THE
VOICES OF STUDENTS INCLUDING
CHEN UP CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL COUNCILS. AND
CALIFORNIA STUDENT BOARD
MEMBERS ASSOCIATION AS YOU CAN
SEE. IN YOUR STAFF REPORT THE
LIST OF MENTAL HEALTH AGENCIES
ADVOCATES NONPROFITS IS VERY
LONG AND SIGNIFICANT. WE NEED
TO DO BETTER WE NEED TO GET
THIS IN PLACE. AND WE NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD AND HELP OUR KIDS
SO THEY CAN HELP THEMSELVES. ON
THE PHONE TO TESTIFY TODAY I
HAVE ZACHARY PATTERSON
PRESIDENT OF THE COALITION
STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
ASSOCIATION AND QUIRKY OVERWORK
A TEACHER AT THE GLENDALE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. THANK
YOU MISTER PORTANTINO AND JUST
TO BE CLEAR YOU DO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS RELUCTANTLY- I
FRANKLY I YOU DO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU RELUCTANT
WE CAN GO TO THE PHONES AND HOW
TO MAKE IT CLEAR RELUCTANTLY I
UNDERSTAND THAT I'VE HAD TO.
ACCEPT MANY RELUCTANT OF IN AND
OUT OF MY STUFF NOT AS A CAN
DURING MY TENURE NOT AS A
CONDITIONS OUT HERE EIGHT BUT
NOT CONDITION TO GET A HEARING.
JUST SO WE'RE CLEAR NOT AS A
CAN I JUST TO BE CLEAR YOU
ACCEPT AMOUNTS IT'S A ONE OUT A
LITTLE ANSWER TO GET HERE. DO
YOU DO ACCEPT THEM I DO ACCEPT
THANK YOU SIR. BUT NOT AS BUT
JUST SO I UNDERSTAND ARE NOT
HAPPY WITH THE AMOUNT NOW BUT I
AND- THE ALL NEED UNDER. IT
WITH THE CAN BE I COULD A
HEARING WITH TWO X. THE AMOUNT
THAT'S- I'VE HAD SAINTS. MYSELF
TIMES IN THIS BILL YOU SHOULD
OWN SO WITH THAT. LET'S GO TO
THE- YOUR WITNESSES YOUR TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH TO
EACH OF THE WITNESSES PLEASE
THANK YOU. NO OPPOSITION. OKAY
THERE'S. ZACHARY PATTERSON I
BELIEVE IS ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT MR PATTERSON
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. ARE YOU
THERE. THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M
HERE. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL UNTIL MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ZACHARY PATTERSON AND I
SERVED AS A MEMBER OF THE SAN
DIEGO BOARD OF EDUCATION BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY AS A STUDENT A
STUDENT WHO FEELS A STUDENT WHO
STRUGGLES AND A STUDENT WHO
KNOWS THAT MY MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELL BEING. IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS PHYSICAL HEALTH
LIKE BREAKING A BONE OR FEELING
SICK WHEN I THINK ABOUT WHY A
SPEAK TO ALL OF YOU TODAY I
THINK IT'S FIRST STUDENT AT MY
SCHOOL JOHN. JOHN WAS MY
CLASSMATE FELLOW TRACK RUNNER
AND FRIEND I TRULY APPRECIATED
JOHN FOR WHO HE WAS A BRAVE BOY
WHO BRIGHTENED UP EVERYONE'S
DAY DESPITE THIS THERE WAS
ALWAYS SOMETHING UNDERLYING THE
INCESSANT JOKES ABOUT SUICIDE
THE FREQUENT SADNESS THAT WOULD
OVERCOME HIM. I DIDN'T KNOW HOW
TO RESPOND AND I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO SO I DID PUT MOST
KIDS WOULD DO UNFORTUNATELY. I
DIDN'T DO TOO MUCH. HELLO
TWENTY TWENTY. MY DEAR FRIEND
JOHN TOOK OWN LIFE. WE WERE ALL
SHOCKED. BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THERE WERE SIGNS. SIGNS THAT I
SHOULD HAVE RECOGNISED. I KNOW
I COULD HAVE DONE BETTER TO
SUPPORT JOHN IF I HAD BEEN
GIVEN THE KNOWLEDGE AND
EDUCATION TO DO SO. AND NOW.
I'M HERE BECAUSE SB FOURTEEN IS
MY CHANCE. IT'S OUR CHANCE. TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LIKE JOHN'S. ACTUALLY
TEACH STUDENTS IN A WARNING
SIGNS AND HOW TO REACT TO A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. ACTUALLY
VALUE MENTAL HEALTH WITH
LEGITIMATE EXCUSED ABSENCES.
AND TO TRAIN TEACHERS ON WHAT
THEY NEED TO NOT ONLY HELP
STUDENTS. BUT ALSO TO HELP EACH
OTHER AS TEACHERS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE DAHLE SPACE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISES AS WELL. YOU CAN
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH AND
REMOVING THE STIGMA AT SCHOOL
IS THE ONLY WAY WE ARE GOING TO
BE SUCCESSFUL IN TURNING THE
TIDE IN SUPPORT OF STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLBEING.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE MADE STRIDES IN
SUPPORTING PROGRAMS THAT
ADVOCATE FOR MENTAL HEALTH. AND
AS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I CAN
PERSONALLY ATTEST TO OUR
EXCITEMENT THE NEW CD YOU
RESOURCES THROUGH THIS BILL
THAT ARE FINALLY DEDICATED TO
THE MENTAL HEALTH OF STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS. ON BEHALF OF
STUDENTS FROM ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
ASSOCIATION I URGE THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. THE SHOW
THE STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
MATTERS AND VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOURTEEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. TO THE NEXT WITNESS. TO
THE NEXT WITNESS CORE HE
OVERCAME BELIEVE. CORKY
OVERWORK IF YOU ARE THERE YOU
MAY PROCEED. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS COURT HERE WORK AND I
HAVE TAUGHT GENERAL EDUCATION
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION FOR THE
LAST THIRTY SEVEN YEARS. I AM
HERE TODAY TO IMPLORE YOU TO
PASS SENATE BILL FOURTEEN THERE
HAS NEVER BEEN A GREATER NEED
TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS AS WE COME BACK FROM
THE MOST ACADEMICALLY SOCIALLY
AND EMOTIONALLY CHALLENGING
YEAR ANY OF US HAVE EVER BEEN
THROUGH. WE NEED. OUR STUDENTS
ARE EXHIBITING SUCH AS
DEPRESSION ANXIETY LACK OF
FOCUS FATIGUE AND IN SOME CASES
SUICIDAL IDEATIONS BUT WE NEED
TO KNOW WHAT TO SAY TO THE
STUDENTS WE NEED TO KNOW HOW TO
ACCOMMODATE THE STUDENTS AS WE
TRY TO COME BACK TO A NEW
NORMAL AND ALSO KNOW WHEN AND
WHO TO REFER THE STUDENT TO. IF
THERE ARE SERIOUS CONCERNS THIS
PAST FALL I HAD TO STUDENTS
WITH DEPRESSION SELF HARM AND
SUICIDAL IDEATIONS THEIR
STRUGGLE WITH SO DEEP THAT THEY
HAD INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES IN
JUST COMPLETING ANY DAILY WORK.
THEY WERE WITH THEIR PARENTS
ALL DAY AND THEY MET WITH A
THERAPIST ONCE A WEEK BUT WHO
DID THEY CONFIDE IN. ME AND IN
THAT MOMENT I NEEDED TO KNOW
WHAT TO SAY AND HOW TO SAY IT.
I CLEARLY FELT INADEQUATE IN
BEING TRAINED TO KNOW WHAT I
WAS SAYING WAS THE RIGHT THING.
AS TEACHERS WE ARE MANDATED TO
DO SEVERAL TRAININGS AT THE
BEGINNING OF EACH SCHOOL YEAR.
THE TEACHERS I HAVE SPOKEN TO
BELIEVE THAT WE DEFINITELY
DEFINITELY NEED MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS TRAINING. JUST THIS
MONTH IN CALIFORNIA EDUCATOR
MAGAZINE EDWEEK RESEARCH CENTER
REPORTS THAT 92% OF EDUCATORS
SAID TEACHING IS MORE STRESSFUL
NOW. BEENPRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
NINETY TWO PERCENT. HOW DO YOU
THINK THE STUDENTS FEEL. IN MAY
AS GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM WAS
ANNOUNCING A MAY REVISED TO THE
BUDGET HE WAS QUOTED AS SAYING
WE NEED TO DO MORE TO CARE FOR
OUR TEACHERS WE NEED TO HAVE
THEIR BACKS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
OUR CHILDREN'S BACK. WELL WE
NEED MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS
TRAINING SO WE CAN TRULY HAVE
OUR STUDENTS BACK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WILL NEXT WILL GO
TO THE OPPOSITION TONY JR GIRL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR PORTANTINO
THIS IS TONY TOOK CARE OF
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE WOULD
FIRST LIKE TO PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THE GREAT WORK OF
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT AND
THE DEPTH. OF HER ANALYSIS OF
SB FOURTEEN WE ALSO WANT TO
THANK SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR
AGREEING TO THE COMMITTEES.
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS AT THE
BOTTOM OF PAGE TEN AM AT THE
TOP OF PAGE ELEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE ACTUAL AMENDMENTS IN
PRINT AND WE ESPECIALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT NUMBER TWO. IS
COMPATIBLE WITH THE SIMPLY BILL
THREE OH NINE ALSO REFERENCED
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AT
THE BOTTOM OF PAGE ELEVEN. CTAS
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE OH NINE
AND ITS PREDECESSOR A. B. SIX
SIX SIX IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
LASTLY WE WOULD BE REMISS BY
NOT MENTIONING THAT C. D. E.
WILL NEED AN APPROPRIATION TO
COMPLETE ITS WORK BY THE
JANUARY TWENTY THIRD TWENTY.
TWENTY THREE DATE IT'S
REFERENCED AN AMENDMENT TO. PTS
COMMITTED TO REMAINING ENGAGED
WITH THE AUTHOR AND BILL
SPONSORS TO REACH AN EQUITABLE
AND MEANINGFUL OUTCOME. AND A
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS CTA
APPRECIATES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE WITH YOU TODAY TO DISCUSS
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU- TO THE AND I
BELIEVE THERE'S NO MORE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO ANY
COMMENTS MANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MR. SINGH NO COMMENTS READY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE ROOM.
YEAH OKAY YOU WANT TO SPEAK
THIS MCCARTY GET THE HEAD OF
THE PHARMACY IT OTHERWISE AND
WE WANT. RELAX OUGHT CLASSROOM
THING WITH THE BILL AND- YOU
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS IS.
AN ONGOING ISSUE THAT YOU KNOW
STUDENT- MENTAL HEALTH SUCCESS
IS ABOUT STUDENT SUCCESS AS
WELL. AND SO WHETHER THIS BILL
OUR STATE BUDGET ALLOCATIONS-
YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA KEEP AT
THIS ISSUE AND- THANK THE
CENTER FOR WORKING ON THIS AND-
AND- LOOK FORWARD TO. WORKING
ON THIS AGAIN IN THE COMING
YEARS IN LEGISLATION INTO THE
BUDGET PROCESS. THANK YOU I'D-
OF WITH THAT- ALSO MAKE A
COMMENT TO I APPRECIATE- THE
SENATOR'S EFFORTS HERE TODAY
THIS ISSUE IS NOT DONE. A IT IS
NOT DOWN THERE IS MORE WORK TO
DO ON THIS ISSUE I THINK WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. AS A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER. I HAD TO DEAL
WITH THIS ISSUE MYSELF. IN A
CLASSROOM SETTING SO THERE IS
MORE WORK TO BE DONE- SO- AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THE FACT THAT
WE WILL HAVE CONVERSATIONS
GOING FORWARD. SO WITH THAT
WE'LL GO TO THE TO KNOW ANY
WITNESS ANY PERSONS IN THE ROOM
WHICH TO TESTIFIED. THE CAPITAL
NOW THE PARK RATHER- AND TO THE
PHONE LINES WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR TEN MINUTES
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE LINES WHAT
YOU MAY DO NOW. IS YOU JUST
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IF
YOU'RE AFFILIATED WITH AN
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY ANYMORE THAN
THAT. THE THE MODERATOR WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALLER WITH
THAT TO THE PHONES PLEASE. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO THE LINE- NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
TERMINAL DANO AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS WENDY
**** REPRESENTING HATHAWAY
SYCAMORES IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB FOURTEEN THANK YOU. FIND
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GREEN ADRIAN SHELTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT OF
S. FOURTEEN. FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS STANDING UP THERE WITH
THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS ALSO KNOWN AS NOBBY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANKS. FINE EIGHTEENTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
SHARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TO RECOMMEND TAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN SUPPORT NOW
WITH THE COMEDIAN AND- THANK
YOU. FIND SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. EACH MORNING
JERRY MEMBERS PERSONAL KIT OR
SOMETHING HAPPENED SANTA MONICA
AND THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS MICHELLE ALISON NINE IN
INFINITE DISTRICT SEVEN AND
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOURTEEN AND
REPRESENTATIVE JOHN UP IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE. NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY WELL I YOU
KNOW AT UC BERKELEY AS WELL AS
THE CONSTITUENT ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTEEN SHALL LOSS OF
THE SENATOR JOHN UP AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CELL.
THANK YOU. TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FAMILY GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
WE SUPPORT SB. FOURTEEN NINETY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S JENNIFER TRAN
UNDERSTAND BY MEMBER INDEED UST
AND I AM FOCUSED ON. SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
AND YET I HAVE NO WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN THANK
YOU. BY NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN WRITTEN
WARNING THERESA ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARTS IN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION IN
SUPPORT. ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
OPEN. NINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ERICA HOPPING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION AND WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED IN COMMITTEE
TODAY WE WILL BE MOVING OUR
POSITION TO A SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL AND ALSO TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF APPRECIATE IT. FIND
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ALLEY HOW THAT
WOULD ADEQUATE WIDENING GROUP
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
COULD SPONSOR TO AT THE
FOURTEENTH SUPPORT. RYAN FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. H. MISTER
KAREN MEMBERS ROB LANG WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES WERE
PROUD SPONSOR AND IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOURTEEN. FIND ONE HUNDRED
YEAR OPEN. HELLO THIS IS KENYA
TARPON SENATE DISTRICT FOURTEEN
IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY ONE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF CHEN UP
IN SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. NINE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PLANNING TO KIND OF
CHECK HI I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
TO A CROWD BECAUSE THEY'RE GOOD
PEOPLE AND WE ARE THE COURT.
THANK YOU. FIND SEVENTY. YOUR
OPEN. VIDEO BORN REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DISAPPEAR TEN WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINETY POINT NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. 17% OF THE HALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPISTS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BLIND FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. RESEARCHER NUMBERS
NICK BROMLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY DISTRICT ADVOCATES FOR
BETTER SCHOOLS AND THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
ALL IN SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE ELSE IS IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU ARE THE AUTHOR
MAKE CLOSE. LIKE TO THANK ALL
OF THE STUDENTS AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT- TOOK THE
TIME TO TESTIFIED THIS MORNING
AND ADD THEIR VOICES TO THIS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT DISCUSSION-
AS YOU CAN TELL- THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. VERY TROUBLING
TO ME AS THE BROTHER OF
SOMEBODY WHO TOOK HIS OWN LIFE.
AND AS A FATHER WHO DOESN'T
WANT TO READ ABOUT MORE KIDS
TAKING THEIR OWN LIVES I THINK
WE DON'T HAVE TIME. I THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE TEACHER TRAINING AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE AND OTHER
PEOPLE OTHER SCHOOL STAFF- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL OUT. OF
THE- RELUCTANTLY. I THANK YOU
MISTER PORTANTINO- WITH THAT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS- DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI-
DONAL I KILEY KILEY I'D SENATE
SENATE I DALLY DALLY I LEE. THE
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE CORK
SILVA. AFP SILVA I'D- FLAWS
SEVEN VOTES IT IS THAT WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM. NUMBER TWELVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE IT'S S. B. TWO
TWO FOUR. YOU MAY PERCEIVE
ALREADY CENTER I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING SENATORS
RUBIO CORTESE TODD GLAZER HUESO
HER TADO LAYERED NIELSEN- CHAU
ABOVE SKINNER AND ON BURKE. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BURKE FRAZIER
CRISTINA GARCIA LACKEY
MAIENSCHEIN WIN RODRIGUEZ AND
SAN DIEGO SANTIAGO EXCUSE ME
FOR ALL BEING CO AUTHORS OF
THIS IMPORTANT BILL TO EXTEND
MENTAL HEALTH EDUCATION TO OUR
K. TWELVE STUDENTS. HAS BEEN
SAID MENTAL HEALTH IS CRITICAL
TO OVER TO FOR THE OVERALL
WELLBEING AND ACADEMIC SUCCESS
OF OUR STUDENTS UNRECOGNIZED
UNTREATED OR LATE TREATED
MENTAL HEALTH ELEVATES THE RISK
OF MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS SUCH AS
SUICIDE AND SELF INJURY
DIMINISHES PROSPECTS FOR
RECOVERY AND CAN CONTRIBUTE. TO
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND OTHER
NEGATIVE COPING BEHAVIORS
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING ONE IN FIVE YOU LIVE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES.
THAT WORKS TO APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION OF OUR KIDS
THAT MAY NEED MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT SERVICES AND THE
NUMBERS ARE MORE DIRE FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND LGBT
Q. PLUS YOU LAST YEAR ONE IN
THREE LGBTQ PLUS YOUTH REPORTED
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING SUICIDE.
STIGMA IS ONE OF THE MAJOR
BARRIERS TO SEEKING HELP IN AS
MANY ASONE HALF TO THREE
QUARTERS OF CHILDREN DID NOT
RECEIVE MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
MENTAL HEALTH EDUCATION IS ONE
OF THE BEST WAYS TO INCREASE
AWARENESS AND EMPOWER STUDENTS
TO SEEK HELP. BY REDUCING THE
STIGMA ASSOCIATED WITH MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM IS THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE SETTING
FOR PROVIDING THIS EDUCATION TO
OUR CHILDREN AS ANYBODY KNOWS
WHO'S HAD A TEENAGER THEY CAN
BE GREAT ADVOCATES FOR
THEMSELVES IF THEY'RE ARMED
WITH INFORMATION- SO THIS BILL
WOULD DO THAT SB TWO TO FOUR
WILL ENSURE THAT PUPILS RECEIVE
MENTAL HEALTH EDUCATION FROM A
QUALIFIED INSTRUCTOR. WILL HELP
THEM IDENTIFY SIGNS OF SYMPTOMS
OF A MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGE
HOW TO SEEK HELP TOO OFTEN THE
GAP BETWEEN LIVING THROUGH
YEARS OF DESPAIR AND SEEKING
HELP IS SIMPLY HAVING THAT MAP
TO GET THE HELP YOU NEED. SB
TWO TO FOUR IS THAT MATT. I'M
AMENDMENTS WE'VE BEEN WE
DILIGENTLY ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY. THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND WE
KNOW THE TEACHERS HAVE BEEN
THROUGH A LOT UNDER COVERT.
THEREFORE THE AMENDMENTS
LIMITING LIMITING MENTAL HEALTH
INSTRUCTION TO ONE JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOLS THAT CURRENTLY OFFER
HEALTH COURSE. BUT THE
AMENDMENTS ALSO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. THAT THIS WILL LIMIT
THE REACH OF THE BILL TO ABOUT
67% OF STUDENTS- WHO ALONG TO
GET THIS MENTAL HEALTH
INSTRUCTION. THE MEMBERS ALSO
STATE THAT AFTER THREE YEARS OF
THIS PILOT AS IT WERE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP A PLAN TO
EXPAND MENTAL HEALTH
INSTRUCTION STATEWIDE. FRANKLY
MENTALLY HEALTHY MENTALLY
HEALTHY STUDENTS EQUALS A
MENTALLY HEALTHY CLASSROOM THE
FLIP SIDE IS THAT MENTALLY
UNHEALTHY STUDENTS WITH HIGHER
DROP OUT AN ATTRITION RATES.
MORE CLASSROOM DISCUSSIONS AND
MORE KIDS LOST. IS YOUR
ANALYSIS POINTED OUT WE LOST A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR KIDS TO
SUICIDE LAST YEAR LET ME SAY
THAT AGAIN. A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR KIDS COMMITTED
SUICIDE LAST YEAR EACH ONE OF
THOSE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
LEAVES BEHIND A GALAXY OF LOVED
ONES. STORIES LAUGHS AND
POTENTIAL. WE'RE LIMITING THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL. WHICH ONES
WERE LIMITING THE REACH. TO GET
THOSE KIDS WHO NEED OUR HELP.
OUR FAMILIES DESERVE BETTER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE GRADING JUST CONFIRMING
YOU DOACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
YES RELUCTANTLY IN ORDER TO GET
A HEARING. THANK YOU HAS ON
FILE WITH THAT- WE CAN GO TO
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- WE
HAVE- TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
IF THEY ARE ON THE LINE THEY
MAY PROCEED WITH THE TESTIMONY
TWO MINUTES. ZOFIA TREXLER I
BELIEVE. YEAH YES MY NAME IS OF
THE EXTRACT FOR. YES YOU YOU
MAY GO AHEAD AND SPEAK SHARE
YOUR TESTIMONY OKAY. YEAH SO
MANY NEW TRACK WHERE I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT NETWORK WHERE
PROGRAM A DENTAL HEALTH AMERICA
CALIFORNIA- AND INTEGRATING
MENTAL HEALTH EDUCATION PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IS REALLY IMPAIRED AND-
IT WOULD REACH THE MAJORITY
BEGIN THANK JUSTIN HOW TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR OWN MENTAL HEALTH
AND TO RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS OF
CRISIS AND APPEARS. REGARDLESS
OF ANY STUDENTS RACE GENDER OR
SOCIOECONOMIC LEVEL OR CULTURAL
BACKGROUND RECEIVE MEDICALLY
ACCURATE INFORMATION. ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS AND THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEM- HOW MANY CHILDREN ARE
EXPERIENCING TRAUMA IN
CALIFORNIA. AYDAN SCIENTIFIC
STUDIES IT CAN LITERALLY TAKE
YEARS OFF YOUR LIFE. ARE
EXPERIENCING ADVERSE CHILD
EXPERIENCES WHEN YOU'RE YOUNG.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE- THAT WE'RE GETTING THREE
KIDS YOUNG AND HELPING THEM.
THE HOBBIT CAPABILITY TO BE
HELPED AND IS THERE MENTAL
ILLNESS AS THE ONLY PERSONALLY
I WAS ONLY FOURTEEN WHEN I
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE. I THINK YOU
THREE HOURS AWAY TO OUR THREE
MARKERS THAT WERE NOT BAD NEWS
FOR EXAMPLE- AND I LOOK BACK AT
THE TIME AND- WORD WE WERE JUST.
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL FOR ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES I'VE RECEIVED THE
ADVOCATE FOR YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH. AND IT REALLY MEANS A
LOT TO ME THAT. THE YOUTH
VOICES SO VALUED BUT THE TRUTH
IS I REALLY SHOULDN'T BE HERE.
MENTAL ILLNESS AND ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES TO
COLLECT SO MUCH OF MY
CHILDHOOD. AND I'LL NEVER GET
THAT TIME BACK WILL BE ABLE TO
REPLACE. WHAT WAS LOST. WELL WE
COULD GO DID OUR LETTUCE
TRAINING- WITH LEGISLATORS. AND
IT WAS CAME AFTER TEN AFTER
CHAIRED. EACH SHARING THEIR
SOME TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE THAT
THEY HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH ONE
OF THEM HE SAID THAT HE WALKED
OUT BECAUSE THE TREND. ONLY A
FEW WEEKS AGO FROM SUICIDE.
WORK YOUNG TO BE GRIEVING THE
LOSS. OF OUR FRIEND AND OUR
CHILDHOOD- BUT EVEN THOUGH IT'S
NOT FAIR RIGHT. WE WILL KEEP
FIGHTING FOR A WORLD IN WHICH
YOU WILL NOT HAVE TO EXPERIENCE
HOW MUCH HER. FIGHT SO HARD TO
HAVE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
BLANK. ON ME WE WILL KEEP
PUSHING AND WE ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
THIS IS JUST ONE STEP. I'M A
VERY LONG ROAD TO CALIFORNIA
THAT SUPPORTS AND CARES FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF OUR YOUTH
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR TIME IS
OVER THANK YOU GOOD JOB- TO THE
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT. LEO
COURSE- CLARK BELIEVE. YEAH
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL
AN HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LOW COST OF CLARK AND
THE FORMER STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
FOR ALL THE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND A MEMBER OF
JENNIFER EXECUTIVE TEAM SB TWO
NOW ALLIN THE MIDDLE OF A
CRISIS A DEFENDER PREVIOUSLY
SAID LAST YEAR IN CALIFORNIA WE
LOST ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR STUDENTS TO SUICIDE EACH
ONE LEAVING BEHIND A HURTING
COMMUNITY AND A GALAXY OF
POTENTIAL. MENTAL ILLNESS IS
NOT EASY TO TALK ABOUT IT IT'S
COMMON FOR THE YEAR THAT THE
SENSITIVE GENERATION I'LL BE
TOLD THAT THE STRESS IS JUST A
NORMAL PART OF SCHOOL BUT IT'S
COMMENTS LIKE THESE THAT REMIND
ME OF THOSE ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR STUDENTS WHO WERE
ONCE JUST LIKE ME THE SOURCE OF
THE STATE A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IS BEYOND JUST STRESS
SADNESS AND ISOLATION. IS THE
RESULT OF COMPLACENCY AT THE
STOMACH FILLING UP EVERY STEP
THEM UP SUPPORT PUT IN PLACE TO
PROTECT STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH
IT IS A CALL TO ACTION TO DO
BETTER WE CAN DO BETTER TODAY
WITH SB TWO TO FORCE
COMPREHENSIVE MENTAL HEALTH
CURRICULUM I SHOULD KNOW I WAS
FORTUNATE TO LIVE IN A SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT OFFERS A MENTAL
HEALTH CURRICULUM EXACTLY LIKE
THE ONE PRESCRIBED THE SPELL.
THROUGHOUT MY PEERS AND I
BECAME MORE WILLING AND ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE OUR OWN SYMPTOMS AND
SEEK HELP AND BECAME BETTER
EQUIPPED TO SUPPORT OUR FELLOW
STUDENTS THAT'S WHY ANY GIVEN
SCHOOL YOU'RE IN ALBANY OVER A
QUARTER OF A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT POPULATION VOLUNTARILY
SPEAKS OUT HELP FOR THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH PUBLIC
COMPREHENSIVE MENTAL CURRICULUM
GOES BEYOND JUST TEACHING
STUDENTS HOW TO RECOGNIZE AND
COPE WITH THEIR SYMPTOS AND
PROVIDE UNIVERSAL SUPPORT THAT
LEGITIMIZES THEIR STRUGGLES
WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND EMPOWERS
THE TO SEEK HELP WITHOUT FEAR.
REPLICATING THE SUCCESS WITH SB
TWO TO FOUR IS AN ESSENTIAL
FIRST STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT IT IS JUST THAT
THE FIRST THAT WILL LIMIT THE
WHOLE CURRICULUM IS PILOTED IN
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL HEALTH
CLASSES IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
WE DEVELOP A PLAN TO EXPAND MY
TO HELP TEACHING TO ALL SCHOOL
LEVELS AND ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. ADDRESSING THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS REQUIRES
CONTINUOUS ATTENTION AND
SYSTEMIC SUPPORT AND THAT
STARTS IN THE CLASSROOM WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH CURRICULUM ON
BEHALF OF. CHEN UP AND STUDENTS
FROM ACROSS CALIFORNIA I URGE
THIS COMMITTEE VOTE IN. OF SB
TWO TO FOUR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE'RE GOING GO TO- AND IS
OFFICE. AS JOE ALL. GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOE LAWSUIT. REPRESENT THE
CITIZENS COMMISSION ON HUMAN
RIGHTS. SPEAKING OPPOSITION TO
STRUGGLE TO FOR BECAUSE IT DOES
NOT ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
INFORMED CONSENT. EACH OF US
HAS THE RIGHT INFORMED CONSENT.
THIS IS NOT JUST AGREEMENT THIS
IS CONSENT TO TREATMENT BASED
ON A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
POTENTIAL BENEFITS AND RISKS.
IS ALSO BASED ON KNOWING OTHER
APPLICABLE TREATMENTS AND THE
RISKS OF RETREAT OF RECEIVING
NO TREATMENT AT ALL. THE
CALIFORNIA PRACTITIONERS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE PATIENT
WITH SUFFICIENT INFORMATION
REGARDING TREATMENT. BUT TO
MAKE A DO YOU THINK YOU HAVE TO
MAKE AN IMPORTANT DECISION
WHETHER OR NOT TO CONSTRUCT TO
THAT TRIP. THE PATIENT MUST
GIVE THIS INFORMED CONSENT THE
FOR THE PRACTITIONER PERFORMS
THE TRICK. THERE ARE TWO
EXCEPTIONS OF THINGS LIKE A
TYPICAL BLOOD DRAW FOR
DIVERGENCE. THE BATTLE
HEALTHCARE STOCKS. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES PROVIDED TO
PATIENTS BLANKS M. S. TWENTY
ONE PATIENTS WORKS- TO. I DON'T
WANT TO RECEIVE INFORMATION
ABOUT YOUR TREATMENT AND TO
PARTICIPATE IN PLANNING YOUR
TREATMENT. NUMBER TWO YOU HAVE
THE CORRECT. KNOWING ONE'S
RIGHTS AND ONE AS A PATIENT.
STUDENTS RECEIVE AN EDUCATION
THAT SHOULD STAY WITH THEM ALL
OVER A LOT. SENATE BILL TWO TO
FOUR WOULD REQUIRE THE STUDENTS
LEARN TO RECOGNIZE MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES AND LEARN THE
WAYS OF RESPONDING TO THE- THEY
SHOULD ALSO LEARN OF THEIR
RIGHT TO INFORMED CONSENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTRUSTED
WITH THAT- WE WILL GO TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
MANY THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEEING NONE- WE'LL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE ROOM SING OUT OF
THE ROOM IN CAPITAL PARK NONE
OF WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
IF YOU'RE ON THE PHONE LINE
WHICH TO SHARE YOUR OPINION
WHETHER AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
YOU SUPPORT THE BILL JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
PLEASE MODERATOR TO THE PHONES.
Q. AND TO DO SO YOU'LL WANT TO
PRESS ONE AND THEN THEY'RE ALL
PERSONAL THAT ALIGNS FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING HEIDI STRONG CEO MENTAL
HEALTH AMERICA CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. LINE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
TREAT THE COMSTOCK THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LINE ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ANY OFFER WITH THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL%
ILLNESS ALSO THAT'S NOT ME
CALIFORNIA OR ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS. ONE OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SURE MEMBERS PERSPECTIVE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE OH THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING ADRIAN SHELTON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE AT
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES WE
ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR AN INBOX
REPORT. THANK YOU. ONE OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CATHY LYNCH REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
HEALTH PHYSICAL EDUCATION
RECREATION AND DANCE AND TRONG
SUPPORT ABOUT SPEAK TO PUBLIC
PARK. TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO THREE
YEAR OPEN. WELL IF WE CAN HEAR
YOU OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH MY
APOLOGIES HI MY NAME IS AJ OURS
LEWIS AND I AM A CURRENT BOARD
MEMBER OF PRODUCTION HOWEVER
THAT WORK AND I AM STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TWO FOUR.
LINE ONE AWAIT YOUR OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY WILL ON
BEHALF OF CHEN I'M I'M A
CONSTITUENT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTEEN MINUTES DO NOT USE THE
BERKELEY AND I'M STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. NINETY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GERMAN
ADONIRAM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS WENDY ****
REPRESENTING HATHAWAY SYCAMORES
WERE BASED IN THE TWENTY FIFTH
SENATE DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AND THREE TWO TWO
FOUR THANK YOU. SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR TRUMP NUMBERS IN THE CALL
ONE MOMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP. OF
SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORTER OF
SB TWO TO FOUR. IN LINE TWENTY
SIX YOU ARE OPEN. RACHEL .COM
HOPE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW CO SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORTER SB TWO TWO FOUR THANK
YOU. LINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CRIPPLER STUDENT CPA
MEMBER IN SUPPORT OF F. B. TWO
TO FOUR. IN NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
I'LL HAVE A LOT OF WITH
WIDENING GROUP MARKETING NEXT
IN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
NUMBER FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHICH MISTER TURN NUMBERS WHILE
PLAYING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. ONE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS TO
BE SNYDER WITH THE FABRIC
INSTITUTE OUR PLEATS TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWO TWO
FOUR THANK YOU. FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS KENNETH CHECK I AM
WAS DISABILITY RIGHT CALIFORNIA
HEARING QUITE A BIT SO. I
TWENTY TWO WE ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FAMILY EVENTS REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND WE SUPPORT SB TWO
TO FOUR. NINETY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. KEVIN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEDIA POINT
REPRESENTING AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION WE ARE IN SUPPORT. AND
ONE A ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
COOPERATE WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT. NINE FORTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS NICK
WRONGLY ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS AND THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE ALL IN
SUPPORT. ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IN NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER TRAINER I'M THINKING
ABOUT MEMBERS EACH YEAR THE AND
AT THE AND I REPRESENTATIVE
CANNOT NINE BOTH A PART OF THE
BILL. LINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JESSICA SACA ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN ALLEN
SUPPORT. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE HUNDRED. HELLO MY
NAME IS TO ME AT HEART I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF JONATHAN
FROM SENATE DISTRICT FOURTEEN
IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY ONE
IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS.
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CAREY MEMBER ISABEL
GARCIA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE IN THE
OFFICE FOR THE COMMISSION
AMENDMENTS WHICH ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AND WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE CO SPONSORS FOR WORKING
WITH SIXTY EIGHT AND THE
AUTHORS SENATORS SHIP ON THE
BILL. AND LINE EIGHT. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MAKING YOUR OPEN. AND
MINE ONE TWENTY TWO YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ALVIN CHAN AND STUDENT BOARD
MEMBER INTELLIGENT COUNTY AND
FROM CHINA AND I FELT. AND
LASTLY HERE HERE ONE NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN- HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ALI AND I'M
BACK IN MY COUNTY AND MENTAL.
HEALTH FOR YOU EMPOWERMENT. AND
I'M AT THE PARK TO FOUR THANK
YOU. PRESIDENT THE BUT WITH
THAT- YOU MAY CLOSE SENATOR. AS
YOU'VE HEARD- SADLY A HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR YOUNG PEOPLE TOOK
THEIR OWN LIVES STUDENTS. WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO.
MAKE SURE THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
THIS YEAR. CURRENT 67% OF THE
STATE IS A GOOD THING. BUT IT'S
NOT THE RIGHT THING- THIS BILL
IN ITS ORIGINAL FORM PASSED THE
SENATE THIRTY NINE ZERO-
OBVIOUSLY I'M GOING TO TAKE 67%
OF THAT'S ALL THAT'S ON THE
TABLE BUT IT MAKES NO SENSE TO
EXEMPT OUT THE REST OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHERE KIDS ARE
JUST AS A NEED AS THEY ARE IN
THE SIXTY SEVEN PERCENT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I. VOTE
I ALSO WANT TO THANK- SOPHIA
AND LEO AND ALL OF THE SPONSORS
AND ALL OF THE FOLKS WHO TOOK
TIME OUT SPECIALLY THE STUDENTS
WHO CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THEIR
OTHER STUDENTS. WE CAN DO
BETTER WE WILL BE BETTER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. YES. I WANTED TO HEAR THE
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC BEFORE
I SPOKE WHICH IS WHY DIDN'T
SPEAK WHEN YOU ASKED US US TWO
TO FOUR YOU KNOW WE GET
OPPORTUNITIES AS LEGISLATORS TO
DO THE RIGHT THING ALL THE TIME
AND WE HEAR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION ALL THE TIME THIS
ISSUE CROSSES MANY SECTORS IT'S
NOT JUST CHILDREN IT'S ALSO
ADULTS THAT WE HAVE LOST MANY
OF US HAVE OUR OWN PERSONAL
FAMILY STORIES RELATED TO
MENTAL HEALTH ELATED TO OTHER
ISSUES THAT COME WITH MENTAL
HEALTH BUT CERTAINLY THERE'S A
STIGMA FOR MENTAL HEALTH
WHETHER IT'S ADULTS. OR EVEN
YOUNG CHILDREN IN ORANGE COUNTY
WE COUNTY WE HAVE- THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL CHALK AND
SADLY THEY OPENED UP AN
ADOLESCENT WARD BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC WHEN I WENT ON A TOUR
I SAID OF COURSE IT WAS
BEAUTIFUL AND HAD ALL THE
THINGS YOU WOULD WANT ADDA
ADOLESCENT HOSPITAL BUT I ASKED
WHY WHAT WHY DID YOU NEED TO DO
THIS SO BECAUSE THEY HAD
ALREADY SEEN THIS IS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. NUMBERS RISING AND
YOUNG GIRLS WITH EATING
DISORDERS AND THIRTEEN AND
FOURTEEN YEAR OLDS CUTTING AND-
OF COURSE SUICIDE ATTEMPTS SO
OF COURSE IT'S INCREDIBLE TO
HAVE A HOSPITAL THERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY. BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
WHY. WHY DO WE HAVE YOUNG
CHILDREN WHO HAVE SUCH BUCK BAD
BODY IMAGES WHO GIRLS WHO FEEL.
THAT THEY NEED TO THROWUP OR
HAVE EATING DISORDERS AND THIS
BILL DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH AND
I KNOW AS A CTA MEMBER MSELF
FOR THIRTY YEARS. WE GET IT
RIGHT SOMETIMES BUT US
CONSTANTLY WARNING TO. WATERED
DOWN OR AMEND BILLS TO MAKE
THEM NOT DO WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO BECAUSE CTA SAYS THIS IS TOO
MUCH I'VE BEEN A CLASSROOM
TEACHER AND TRAINING IS
IMPORTANT AND WE NEED TO HAVE
THIS TYPE OF TRAINING NOT ONLY
FOR TEACHERS BUT SO THAT
TEACHERS CAN TEACH IT TO OUR
STUDENTS AND WE NEED TO BE
ADDRESSING IT AT YOUNGER AND
YOUNGER ISSUES SO I AM VERY
DISAPPOINTED THAT INTO BILLS
THAT CAME FORWARD UNDER MENTAL
HEALTH AND I BROUGHT ABOUT BY A
BILL MYSELF THAT DID NOT EVEN
GET A HEARING. WE ARE MISSING
THE BOAT AND MISTER CHAIR I
HAVE ALL RESPECT FOR YOU- BUT
TO THE CTA PEOPLE WHO ARE
LISTENING. WE ARE MISSING THE
BOAT AND KIDS ARE DYING ON OUR
WATCH AND I AM TIRED OF IT. I
SUPPORT YOUR BILL BUT IT
DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH. THANK
YOU- THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS DO WE
HAVE A MOTION YOU DON'T. THE
NEW EMOTION. IT'S BEEN MOVED
AND MR LEE SECONDS AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS HERE
TODAY WE DO NEED TO FIGURE THIS
OUT. BUT WE NEED TO FIGURE IT
OUT TOGETHER WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE- IN
AND REMEMBER THAT SCHOOLS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR A LOT OF
THINGS. AND NOW IT IS GOING YOU
KNOW IT AS WE MOVE DOWN THE
TIME IND. MENTAL HEALTH IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE PART OF
THE CONVERSATION. ONE OF THE
ELEMENTS OF THIS BILL. INADA
TALKS ABOUT THE HIGH SCHOOL
HEALTH CLASS RIGHT GREAT PLACE
TO TEACH MENTAL HEALTH BUT- ALL
HIGH SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA NOT
REQUIRED EVEN HAVE HEALTH
CLASS. THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO TALK ABOUT AS WELL SO
THERE'S A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
THAT NEED TO BE HAD ABOUT THIS
TOPIC. AND OTHER TOPICS BUT WE
NEED TO MOVE TOGETHER WITH THAT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MISTER
CHAIR FOR MAKE MAKE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THIS CALL CONTAMINANT
OR COMMENT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL. HI
THE DONALD HI KILEY. KILEY AYE
BENNETT. BENNETT I DALY. DALLI
EYES LI. LI MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE. CORK SILVA. THANKS OF I'D-
THE BILL IS OUT THANK SENATOR.
WE HAVE ADD ONS TO DO OF
MEMBERS COULD JUST. THOSE THOSE
MEMBERS WHO HAVEN'T. VOTED ALL
BILLS PLEASE STAY BECAUSE WE
WILL ADD ON NOW. CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
CORK SILVA. KIRK SILVA I'D.
FILE ITEM ONE SB SIX NINETY TO
THE CHAIR VOTING I. HE. FILE
ITEM ONE SB SIX NINETY TO THE
CHAIR VOTING I LEAD. LEAI
MCCARTY. HE SAID I- MCCARTY I.
FILE ITEM SEVEN SB FIFTY THE
CHAIR VOTING I LEAVE. LEAI FILE
ITEM NINE SB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
THE CHAIR VOTING I'D SENATE.
SENATE HIGHLY THE I. GREAT I
THANK YOU MEMBERS I WANNA THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK THIS
IS OUR LAST HEARING I DON'T
THINK COMMITTEE STAFF BOTH
SIDES OF COURSE WHO DO A
WONDERFUL JOB IN ADVOCATING OF
FOR THEIR BELIEFS THEIR CAUSES
SO THANK YOU- ONE THINK THE
SERGEANTS ALWAYS EIGHTEEN T.
THAT CAN'T BE AN EASY JOB BEING
A MODERATOR. ON THESE PHONE
LINES IT GETS PRETTY TECHNICAL
AND PRETTY DIFFICULT REAL
QUICK. SO AGAIN- I THINK THE
MEMBERS- FOR THEIR HARD WORK
THIS YEAR. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
MORE WORK NEXT YEAR. THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.